Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, dann bis zum nächsten Mal.
Voltor- nine.
cube
ady
Xcident
Leute ich bin auf was ist denn los hier ich komme wieder und der hype train ist schon auf 490 was ist denn hier los
Chirato 222 exzellenz subscription
Der virus bln tier 1 sub dankeschön
Ach du scheiße du suchst du suchst dir aber auch immer die besten themen aus oder
Keine ahnung
Der eichler 19 monate das ist ja wahnsinnige hyper subscription hier schon wieder
Danke für die sub
Für die sub excellent
Serion vier monate huge sub IQ plus plus für den chat wieder
Nein also ich habe keine ahnung warum warum das da probleme
Da habe ich mich ich habe mir noch keine gedanken zugemacht was willst du denn daheim multicasten
So leute ich bin heute ein bisschen stinkig und zwar chat nicht mit euch
Der chat ist wie immer messen
Dhl hat das habe ich ja vergessen dhl auch ja noch noch ein weiterer grund warum ich angepisst sein muss
Und zwar ich war mal kurz meine vm an kann man immer gebrauchen
Kurz meine vm an ja dhl dann fangen wir fangen wir doch mal mit dhl an ja
Um nicht zu sagen dhl express
Exzellenz simply delivered ihr habt übrigens gesehen ich habe das dhl video weggemacht
Das liegt aber nicht daran dass dhl das geschafft hat oh mist jetzt habe ich verraten ich wollte euch gerade fragen
Chat was meint egal ich frage ich frage euch jetzt trotzdem was meint ihr hat's dhl geschafft meine sendung aus den usa zuzustellen oder nicht
Natürlich haben sie es nicht geschafft ich habe das dhl video gelöscht das hat im prinzip ja keine kein kein sinn gehabt wobei ich überhaupt wobei
Wir müssen bevor ich mit mit mit mit mit dhl sag müssen da auf youtube bin ich auch stinkig
Ich habe mir jetzt wirklich mühe gegeben in letzter zeit mit den videos ich habe immer schön regelmäßig videos gemacht
Und man kann auch nicht sagen dass die wir nicht aufrufen
Bekommen hätten ne guckt euch das mal an also ich meine das ist mehr als so so anderer mit meinen abo zahlen hat das ist nicht wenig
und seit
6 7 tagen hat sich youtube gesagt nein wir empfehlen keine videos von max mehr
Ich habe nämlich auf einen schlag keine abos mehr bekommen seit
Glaub vor seit sechs tagen gibt gibt einfach keine mehr einfach einfach ich sonst habe ich irgendwie so am tag so
War war zu geschwankt sag mal mal 20 bis 150 so je nachdem was war wenn ganz viel war oder so sodass ich im monat irgendwie auf
1000 bis 2000 maximal 3000 jetzt gekommen bin
Und aber ich krieg seit sechs tagen gibt es einfach es gibt gar keine mehr gar keine es hat einfach komplett aufgehört ja
Es gibt einfach keine mehr
Es hat einfach komplett aufgehört ja es gibt natürlich die üblichen de abos die es immer gibt
Man hat ja standardmäßig immer einen gewissen stream an die abos
Und und das problem ist ihr kennt mich ich bin sehr stonks fokussiert was sowas angeht
Wenn ich nicht sehe dass zumindest die zahlen grün sind habe ich kein bock mehr
Deswegen sollte mich youtube nicht weiter zu bäden
Sonst gehe ich zum mixer
Ach nee zu facebook gaming
Shadowband ich glaube nicht dass youtube kanäle random shadowband
Mal zum agenter streaming genau
Wir haben ja schon von proxmox gehört nee haben die was neues rausgebracht gab es neue version
Ach nee du meinst ob ich insgesamt schon mal was davon gehört habe ja ja habe ich
Haben wir sogar schon im stream ausprobiert ich muss dir ehrlich sagen
Für mich war es jetzt nichts aber ich bin generell äußerst unzufrieden mit allen möglichen fertig lösungen
Weil es da immer irgendwas gibt was mir nicht gefällt
Und ich habe nach wie vor hier mein ubuntu server laufen und das war es mehr brauche ich da auch nicht
Vielleicht weil du hassymbole wie pepe
Also has aus meinen thumbnails zu erkennen ist so wirklich äußerst weit rein interpretiert ja nee ich glaube einfach mal
Ich denke einfach mal das ist youtube randomness ja
Ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwas wäre bescheuert
Das ist einfach random das ist einfach random hast du was war hast du was immer hast du nix ja
Das versteht man nicht so genau bei youtube
Warum du so einfach bist
Ja
Warum denken eigentlich gerade alle die keine zahlen mehr ist gute frage muss ja
Was sonst kann er nicht sein dass es täuscht keiner mehr gucken will muss ja immer wieso wer denkt das denn
Wer denkt das denn alles oder wer sagt dass er dass er shadow bunt wurde youtube shadow bunt doch keine leute das wäre doch also wenn auf youtube
Ein ein shadow bunt dann bin ich das mit leute die irgendwie dummes zeug in den kommentaren spammen
Aber youtube wäre auch total bescheuert wenn die sachen die aufgerufen werden nicht zeigen das wäre einfach nur fail da wird sich youtube doch ins eigene fleisch leiten
Das war wer auch knackt ich glaube eher das ist einfach random ja also ich glaube das ist einfach random
Die letzten drei videos waren vielleicht nicht jedermanns sache gewesen seit daran wird es das wird sicherlich auch mitliegen
Ich meine muss ja auch mal vielleicht eins zwei videos bringen können jetzt in innerhalb von zwei monaten die nicht so geil ankommen ohne dass das empfehlen
Komplett instant eingestellt wird
Was ich bestellt habe aus den usa habe ich letztes mal schon bezeigt fünf fünf stück davon
Bei dem shop adafruit wobei adafruit ist es ja wahrscheinlich adafruit fünf stück habe ich bestellt
Und äh
Equate man konnte es doch auf fünf stellen und jetzt hängt es bei dhl
Und equate man konnte es doch auf fünf stellen und jetzt hängt es bei dhl
Ach youtube erzählt viel wenn der tagen lang ist ich glaub dir nix
So ähm übrigens wenn ihr was wissen wollt schreibt at wo bloß dabei sonst sonst sehe ich es echt nicht ich hab's jetzt hier nur zufällig gesehen
Also wadoki du kannst damit natürlich das ist ein vollwertiger ledigungsrechner das heißt du kannst alles mitmachen was geht
Die frage ist jetzt nur die man sich stellen muss
Äh was treten das sage ich gleich die frage die man sich jetzt nur stellen muss ist
Was ist das projekt was irgendwie einen mehrwert bringt dass man es nicht einfach nur
Baut weil man bauen will es ist da nicht verkehrt weil man einfach nur was baut weil man bauen will
Aber es ist natürlich schon ein bisschen motivierender auf dauer wenn man auch sachen macht die man braucht ja und das
Kann ich dir schlecht sagen weil ich weiß ja nicht
Was du brauchst ja
Manche leute sagen sowas wie einen dns proxy
Nicht ein dns proxy in den ja doch so also so ein adblock proxy dns mäßig wäre ganz sinnvoll bin ich jetzt persönlich kein allzu großer fan
Hast du das wire guard desaster von pf sens netgate gehört nee
Haben die gemacht
Wire got removed warum das denn
Weil die wollen die wollen die mich rollen oder was
Also ich kann dir ich kann dir sagen dass ich kann dir sagen was ich was ich laufen habe
Auf nicht auf meinem raspberry pi aber ich kann dir sagen was ich für vom server laufen habe plus das was ich auf dem raspberry pi habe
Also ich habe für meinen 3d drucke
habe ich einmal
Das da laufen
Die abseite sieht ein bisschen pains schämen mich aus das kannst du dein 3d drucke steuern dann habe ich im keller
Das habe ich schon eine weile nicht mehr gezeigt
Dann habe ich im keller den raspberry pi 0 der liest meine heizung aus dass ich hier so nice dashboards krieg
Es habe ich noch nie gezeigt oder wie findet ihr das chat
Glaubt das ist was ganz neues
Na ja das ist ein raspberry pi raspberry pi 0 unten im keller
Der der heizt genau steht das munter auch dass das muss ich noch mal ich muss noch heizt schimpf nennen
So also dann habe ich im raspberry pi 0 laufen der macht im keller noch luftfeuchtigkeit und
Temperatur mit liest aus
Dann mir fällt das immer so schwer das alles aus dem kopf auf zu sagen weil das mittlerweile so viel so viel gedöns ist
Dann habe ich hier noch den raspberry pi zum basteln rumliegen den 4er
Aber ich habe noch ein unten der unify controller und für die ganzen
Überwachungskameras dann habe ich noch raspberry pi 0 für eine überwachungskamera draußen an der klingel
Mit der raspberry pi cam mit so einer ganz kleinen
Pi 0 mini kamera weiß gar nicht
Wenn genau 0 ja so eine hier so eine richtig kleine furzkamera ist das
Die ist also die ist das erkennt man jetzt gar nicht aber die ist wirklich gleich du siehst hier guck mal hier unten
Hier unten ist der anschluss am raspberry
Wait a minute
Was machen die da
Warum stecken die das kabel in in den mikro sd-slot das gehört überhaupt nicht hin
Hä
Fertig was was ein schwachsinn bild
Das kommt die kamera kommt da dran hier
Hier unten kommt die kamera dran die kommt nicht in den mikro sd-slot
Na ja gut vielleicht sollte es auch einfach nur exemplarisch sein aber das ist zumindest verkehrt
Also das das habe ich auch eine an
an der klingel an der tür
so
Was habe ich noch glaube ich habe noch ein paar esp 32 laufen für jetzt zum strom
strom zählen unten
Und ja und auf meinem server habe ich auch jede menge dienst noch laufen von
kleinteile hardware verwaltung bis zu einem wiki leider noch nextcloud was ich aber nur verwendet wenn es unbedingt sein muss
den files server
px e boot
Ich weiß es aus dem kopf jetzt gar nicht mal alles aber ich glaube da war jetzt genug dabei oder
Frage beantworte natuki irgendwas war vielleicht dabei
Was er hauptsächlich gehäuse ich habe beispielsweise letztens
also um genau zu sein gestern
Hab ich wieder ein neues gehäuse für den watt champ ausgedruckt ja ich war ja noch dabei zu erzählen warum ich warum ich gerade ein
bisschen angepisst bin
also
Dhl ich mache das jetzt mal der reihe nach sonst verzettel ich mich hier wieder
Also erstens die geschichte mit youtube das habe ich euch erzählt warum leider nextcloud kann ich gleich was zu sagen
Weil ich nextcloud nicht weil mich eigentlich nextcloud zum größten teil nervt also dhl hat es natürlich nicht geschafft
Ich habe ja dhl express am start bestellt wie gesagt das video habe ich gelöscht für all die sich mitgekriegt haben ich habe in den usa
5 stück hiervon bestellt so kleine microcontroller
Aber ich wusste gar nicht dass es die noch kleiner gibt ach du scheiße da gar nichts mehr dran
Und die habe ich aus den usa bestellt weil das ist nicht bei den china chinesen gibt
Das gibt es nur in den usa das ist irgendein bastler aus den usa der die der diese dinger baut so
So habe ich aus den usa bestellt und man kann ich zeige es euch jetzt einfach mal man kann bei denen an
ankreuzen
Wenn man das jetzt kaufe will wahren korb
Ja, please
so paypal check out blablabla und im check out prozess kann man
keck wl 0 w.com lasst mich doch einfach mal was zeigen ich bestellst
Das geht nicht
Meine gelt meine güt ich will euch da einfach nur ich bestellts doch in an ich will euch einfach nur die shipping options zeigen
Haben wir es jetzt was okay?
Jetzt jetzt darf ich jetzt
Exzellent so die zwei sachen gibt es zum auswählen express world wide und
Genau du kannst die 2 sachen auswählen
Und genau du kannst auswählen express world wide und du bezahlst additional 25 dolla dass die für dich
Steuern und und soll machen
Klingt erst mal gut weil bezahlen musste den scheiß eh und ich habe mir gedacht ey wenn ich mich nicht ums handling kümmern muss ist okay
Alles in ordnung
Das problem ist nur dass dhl es absolut nicht
Geschissen bekommt
Das liegt jetzt seit über einer woche beim zoll in leipzig
Ich habe schon zweimal mit ihnen telefoniert ich habe zweimal zolldokumente hochgeladen wohlgemerkt
Also sprich prepaid custom and taxes also sprich die die die wollen sollen das eigentlich für mich machen ja also total hängen geblieben
Das nächste mal mache ich einfach das und sparen mir das geld und macht es mit dem zoll direkt und die kriegen es nicht gebacken
Und der letzte ratschlag von der eine an der hotline war ja laden sie den kram doch einfach noch mal hoch
Und wenn sich dann zwei bis drei tage nichts getan hat dann rufen sie noch mal an
Ich meine mal ernsthaft was ist das für einen saftladen das kann doch nicht wahr sein so also sagt gut next
Also das bin ich auch schon mal gerade ein bisschen stinkig das mit youtube habe ich und das nächste ist der watt champ hat ein problem
Wer den watt champ nicht kennt
Das ist der watt champ
Ich habe eine grafische
Microcontroller-projekt gebastelt ich zeige euch das mal in gross in in big
Habe ich letztes mal schon gezeigt da für die nicht dabei waren
Hallo und kannst du jetzt nicht einfach in huge machen
Genau also ich hab sch lap gehäuse gedruckt ich hab für jeden sensor in den gehäuse gedruckt
ja wie Garrett so wie ich
schönes gehäuse gedruckt ich habe für jeden sensor in gehäuse gedruckt ja ich
habe mir sogar mal mühe gegeben das ordentlich anzulöten alles alles gut ja
so und das ist der controller einen von denen ich jetzt auch noch aus den usa
bestellt habe so habe ich den keller heute nachmittag bin ich in keller
runter habe das angeschlossen habe erst mal gesehen okay kein wlan empfang im
keller was überhaupt nicht sein kann weil ich habe ja dann den raspberry pi
und eine kamera im keller beides über wlan bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin
dass es dass das ding irgendwie probleme mit dem access point im im
erdgeschoss hat ja wenn ich über meinen access point jeder hinter mir steht ist
überhaupt kein problem wenn ich so mit dem access point macht der im erdgeschoss
steht verbindet sich das ding ums verrecken nicht geht einfach nicht also
habe ich noch mal alles ausgemacht abgemacht hochgegangen habe mal die
channels von hand am access point eingestellt und siehe da er mag den
access point nur er mag den access point nur im erdgeschoss wenn es auf channel
elf steht warum auch immer das eigentlich kein problem das guckt er
sich normalerweise beim verbinden an ich habe da mal ein anderes sp 32 bord
genommen das hat absolut gar keine probleme sich zu dem access point im
erdgeschoss zu verbinden so habe ich aber ok passt in keller eingebaut wlan
verbindung erkannt gut ich habe alle sensoren angeschlossen schön
angeklebt war alles gut verbaut nicht gewackelt gut hat funktioniert bin ich
hoch habe gedacht ok gehst du auf die webseite ich habe so einen kleinen web
server drauf laufen gehst du auf die webseite und habe ich festgestellt aha ich hab
mich ich muss noch mal ich muss noch mal ein update machen kann man ja alles über
die webseite machen habe ich über die webseite versucht ein firmware update
hochzuladen und es hat nicht funktioniert er ist immer mitten im
update gecrasht immer
also bin ich noch mal in keller habe alles wieder abgemacht und dann kam der
hit ich habe ihn hier oben wieder angeschlossen den controller so sieht
er so sieht das aus wenn er an ist dann steht hier vorne auf dem display was
drauf ich habe ihn oben wieder angeschlossen
der ist 20 zentimeter vom access point weg hier oben keine verbindung mehr
und seitdem ich den abgestoppt haben und hier hochgebracht habe keine verbindung
mehr ich konnte das ding nie wieder überreden verbindung zu meinem wlan
herzustellen
keine ahnung ich habe neue firmware geflasht
vergiss es ist kaputt geht nicht mehr was ich noch mal machen könnte ich könnte
wlan scannen lassen und gucken was da das ding kommt voll für den arsch
komplett kaputt macht dafür nichts mehr das wäre das dritte bord was ich was ich
kille was 20 euro das stück kostet ja ich brauche das bord zum beispiel für so
klein scheiß weil guck mal hier kriegst du nichts anderes gescheit rein
guck mal wie eng das ist jetzt schon mit mit dem anderen zeug also gerade für so
klein kram wie im schallschrank oder was ist denn da im wie nennt man das ding im
keller der verteilerschrank ist das halt gold wert der scheiß aber es richtig
ja krepp hätte ich gewusst dass der kacke so anfällig ist ich weiß nicht ob
ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht hat zumindest das verbindet sich einfach
nicht mehr mit dem wlan da war ich auch denke ich weiß auch zwei stunden
gedauert bis der kram funktioniert hat was zum was ist das
ich überlege gerade wann man das braucht
einfach ein großes gehäuse bauen fall fett habe ich gemacht ich wollte euch
nämlich da ich habe jetzt ein neues gehäuse ausgedruckt und zwar nicht
schneißes gehäuse ja nach was muss man dazu
ich habe einem gehäuse für das display gesucht nein dhl ist nicht angekommen so
ich habe richtig dickes gehäuse ausgedruckt digga realtorc lost richtig
lost so hier sagen warum ist warum hat man eine suche wenn das nie in der
richtigen reinfolge ist zumindest das gehäuse allein schon hat wieder
dreieinhalb stunden gedruckt dafür ist es jetzt richtig schönes großes gehäuse
das da habe ich ausgedruckt genau ich meine ist für den d1 mini aber es egal
kannst du alles reinlegen
das habe ich mir ausgedruckt oder habe ich das zeug eingebaut
liegt jetzt liegt jetzt hier neben mir weil es funktioniert nicht
ja da war ich echt angepisst zwei stunden umsonst im keller rum gewurstet
und das hat nicht funktioniert ja so sieht es aus
ja ich verstehe es auch nicht zumal das dumme ist die anderen die anderen
versandarten die die haben sind auch nicht besser benutzt du klipper du
meinst dieses dieses clipboard management ding von kde ne ich habe
plötzlich was anderes die anderen bestellen bestellen ja die hatten
nämlich nur den einsatz deswegen habe ich nicht gekauft wie teuer ist
eigentlich die tinte für den 3d drucke ich habe noch nie was nachgekauft aber
wahrscheinlich nicht so teuer
das nehme ich noch der alte gibt jetzt einen neuen naja scheiß drauf zumindest
bin ich deswegen echt angepisst gewesen drei sachen die mir auf den sack gehen
dhl youtube und der watschamp
ne klipper für den 3d drucker was was moment was sind klipper das muss ich
jetzt mal angucken ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
wasser ich hasse solche hintergrund bilder leute
gehst du fort
also nicht wegen wasser sondern wegen
sondern wegen tiefem wasser das kann ich kann ich wo ist der firefox hin
tiefes wasser kann ich nicht ab das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt
kennt kennt das noch jemand
es gibt demo und mini für die wollte ich mir tatsächlich mal kaufen das ist ein
guter gut das ist ein guter einwand den wollte ich mir schon die ganze zeit mal
bestellen und mal den demo und mini erst für den erst die sp 32 variante
probieren
ich habe noch ein paar sp 266 da ja was ist denn das jetzt für einer
es ist jetzt in sp 32 sp der sieht moment ist in sp 23 stadt 2 2 rein löscher
die aber leute nochmals mal mal mal mal interesse halber so hintergrund bild
da gibt es bestimmt namen für kennt ihr das angst vor tiefem wasser das genau so
hieß das so heißt das ist also nicht mal nicht mal tiefes wasser ich habe gar
kein problem mit tiefem wasser solange ich drinne also solange ich eine
taucherbrille an ab und kann unter das wasser gucken ist das gar kein problem
aber ich hasse das wenn man ins wasser reingucken das spiegelt sich dann so und
und wenn sich sachen im wasser spiegeln zum beispiel zum beispiel gibt es in
frankfurt das rebstock bad weiß gar nicht ob es es noch gibt
rebstock bad war übelst nice da gibt es so wellen und sowas ich war war schon mal
eine rebstock bad bei euch übelst nice in frankfurt die haben so die
haben so ein wellen wellen machmaschine drin weiß ich ob man das hier sieht
zumindest die haben den sprung becken das ist 3,7 meter tief sprung becken spring
sprung sprung weiß ich ob es ein bild von gibt dass dahinten irgendwo
ist dahinten irgendwo das ist das sprung becken leute das sind die 3,7
meter tief und unten ob ich das jetzt irgendwie
so und übrigens die rutsche ist auch mega nice die geht von hier oben wasser
rutscht außen rum moment warte mal wie lang geht die eigentlich es gab zwei in
der kleinen und großen die geht außen rum raus und dann in einem anderen raum
unter das ist das ist mega nice ja so und hier ihr seht das schon unten in
diesem sprung becken das 3,7 meter tief da konnte man gut ein bisschen bisschen
tauchstelle zu üben als ich klein war und unten geht auch so einen so einen weg
vorbei also sprich man kann runter tauchen zu einem fenster und dann kann
man sich so so geräte angucken die da rumstehen halt die das dann wahrscheinlich
halt halt technikraben für schwimmbad dass das funktioniert war immer super
spannend und ich hatte übelst angst in das wasser zu gehen wie ich klein war
weil ich bin immer auf das becken zugegangen ich also auch auch wenn ich
schon oft drinnen war total hängen geblieben ja ich weiß auch nicht warum
ich war da schon total oft drin ist nie was passiert so und ich gehe immer an
ich gehe dann von der seite an das becken ran und ihr seht doch hier so die
spiegelung in dem wasser und du erkennst es von oben nicht genau was das ist und
und du denkst dir unter unter bewusst das sind irgendwelche riesen fische die
dich auffressen wenn ins wasser gehst oder so ich weiß ich vielleicht vielleicht
kennt das irgendeiner ich das ist das ist das ist auf jeden fall irgendeine
störung das nicht normal ja so und ich habe mich da nie reingetraut in das
wasser jedes mal jedes mal habe ich mich nicht reingetraut und bis ich dann halt
drinnen war ich hatte immer übel schiss reinzugehen und wenn ich mich dann
getraut habe reinzugehen und war unter wasser mit der taucherbrille auf dann
ist gar kein problem easy unter wasser mit der taucherbrille da
habe ich ja alles gesehen gar kein problem
so deswegen kann ich auch nicht kann ich ich kann schon aber deswegen gehe ich
ungern in baggaseen und sowas weil in einem baggasee siehst du nichts
weder mit taucherbrille noch wenn du oben drauf bist und ich habe immer ich
habe immer irgendwie unter bewusst schiss wenn ich auf der luftmatratze
rum paddeln oder rum schwimmen oder so oder noch schlimmer wenn man wirklich
in den fisch einem ans bein schwimmt so was kleines oder so da habe ich übelst
panik was ist irgendwas großes gefährliches ist keine ahnung
so deswegen mag ich kein tiefes wasser wo ich nicht erkenne was sache ist ja und
in den wasser wo so ein wahl drin ist würde ich im leben da dreien
ja es gibt es hat jeder so sein gestörten sachen ja ja exzellent wunderbar
naja gut wo sind wir stehen geblieben wie gesagt hauptsächlich gehäuse aber hier
ich werde mir ich werde mir da vor davon mal bestellen ich meine 325 was
willst du da großartig verkehrt machen das ist 325 das ist richtig neiser
chinesen preis also gibt es eine ordentliche lieferung nach d
näh
für den mal schlimmer ok es war das ischina kreppler da dauert es halt
sind graben eigentlich auch die e
wow ok in deutschland ist der graben schon einfach mal auf einen schlag
doppelt so das war noch der alte 20 durch 3 das ist doppelt so teuer
china packchen kommen nicht mehr durch wie warum nicht warum soll china packchen nicht
mehr durchkommen kanal zu ja dann muss man so bestellen dass es im
flieger landet aber warum ist er warum ist er zu oh oh was das oh das ist
schlecht
ich habe deine videos geschaut aber gar nicht gecheckt was du für ein teil in
deiner weißen box bastelst du meinst das hier das da das ist zum stromzähler
ablesen das da ist ein temperatur luftfeuchtigkeits sensor das da ist ein
sensor der striche erkennt einfach gesagt damit kann zum beispiel so eine
alte zählscheibe auslesen und das hier was zu ist ist ein sensor der leds erkennt
wenn sie blinken daran kann ich den stromzähler oben aus auslesen
oh das ist schlecht wenn wenn wenn die verbindung nach china zu ist das sagt
ok da müssen wir anderweit bestellen aber nicht aber definitiv nicht per dhl
dhl mache ich dann mal das könne das könne das könne vergessen
warte mal lass mal lass mal kurz schauen
ich mein 6 euro amazon kann man sich aber geben
aber lieber wär mir direkt aus china
das schöne ist man kann es gut dran erkennen wenn er zwei reihen pins hat dann ist es der
esp 32 und ansonsten ist der esp 266 vielleicht haben nämlich glück und
irgendeiner hat eu waren lager versandt das ist was was ich in aliexpress nicht
so wirklich mag man man kann irgendwie nicht
schiff aus germany man kann irgendwie nicht richtig auswählen eu waren lager
und so was das geht das geht bei bengut besser
beide wey leute ich habe eine richtig gute idee gehabt weil jemand einer was
von blokka vorhin geschrieben hat wollen wir mal einen stream machen wo ich mir
mal sowohl als als auch angucke was mir besser gefällt ich habe ich vor zwei
drei jahren ausprobieren auch gar nicht vielleicht kann es ja vielleicht
erinnern das ja meine meinung da drüber als dass dass man das nicht braucht
die kuk die haben alle aliexpress saver chipping shipping wenn das dauert noch
länger aber es ist saver safer also immer
erster juni what the fuck
vielleicht bestelle ich mir doch mal einen dreier pack bei amazon.de weil die
wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren ich habe ja noch ein paar übrig sp 266
davon die fand ich immer gut die sind nur einen ticken größer als die anderen
ich nutze einfach brav hab kein adblocker installiert da wo man das machen
kann bringt das was ich habe ja auch nur im browser aber zum beispiel in der
youtube app oder in der twitch app kannst du das schon mal nicht machen und
ich krieg es garantiert meiner mutter nicht erklärt dass sie nicht mehr
safari verwenden soll wobei man mittlerweile glaube ich
unterm neck auch was systemweit installieren kann unter ios naja
gut wunderbar wie bin ich jetzt darauf gekommen leute brain lag
ja also ich glaube ich bestelle ich mache mir das mal kurz mal nebenbei bei amazon
auf dass ich das nicht vergesst esp aber ich mache mal hier jetzt lasse ich
einfach in tab auf mini sp 32 gibt es da irgendwas liefert bis freitag liefert
bis freitag ach ja bei der way jetzt wo ich das hier gerade sehe ich habe mir
davon zwei stück bestellt ich habe mir einen 24 zoll ein 2,8 zoll bestellt das
ist so ein fertiges fertiges set mit display gehäuse und ordentlichen platine
wo man dann den controller drauf machen kann seiner wahl ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ehrlich gesagt ob 25 euro gerechtfertigt sind aber ich werde es mal
ausprobieren weil ich finde es an sich eine coole idee 2,4 zoll nicht 24 zoll
cac weight ich finde es an sich eine coole idee weil es ja im prinzip ähnlich
ist zu dem was ich hier von hand zusammen gebaut hat ne controller sensoren display
und hier kriegst du halt schon in gehäuse plus das display und kannst den
controller den du willst ja auf die platine bauen
ich glaube das ist eine ganz coole idee ob es 24 euro 25 euro wert ist muss ich
mal gucken
so genau dass das wollte ich mir angucken was ist denn das wire garth
desaster wire garth removed from pf sens warum
warum achso kernel mode wire garth has been removed from bsd warum das denn
warum hat bsd das entfernt was kostet e-paper mit touch bei aliexpress gute
frage touch ja so was in der größe teuer das ist doch kein aber das ist kein
e-paper das ist ganz normales lcd oder meister allgemein so aber warum ist
wire garth aus dem bsd karnel geflogen
haben die irgendwas haben die in aus verkackt und jetzt
removed warum
now the existing wire kernel code was removed but
ok na gut da kann jetzt pf sens ja auch nicht allzu viel machen wenn die
halbwegs aktuelle freebsd version verwenden wollen da sollte flash bang
also ich wäre jetzt angepisst sage ich euch ehrlich gesagt ich wäre jetzt
angepisst wenn ich das verwenden würde da wäre ich jetzt ein bisschen stinkig
aber bin ich nicht gönnen dir noch ein paar microcontroller von dem sub was
also ja guck mal ich bin überhaupt nicht aktuell ich habe die ganzen subs gar
nicht gesehen ich gehe jetzt mal hier schneller immer kurz schnell chat durch
alles klar wenn wir kommen hier ich bin übel zu weit hinten dran wie liest du
das aus dem keller aus das lese ich hier drüber aus und das ist ein opto link
kabel kann man sich selbst bauen muss man nicht kaufen ist sonst ein bisschen
teuer usb das ist ein fucking kabel mit zwei infrarot leds warum wollen die 70
euro dafür haben sind die sind die doch irgendwie ganz bei trost oder was
na gut das kannst du ein paar usb eine raspberry pi anschließen und auf der
anderen seite an die heizung und dann kannst du das mit dem open source tool
auslesen kann ich kann ja auch zeigen was welches wie baut man so ein opto link
kabel selber ich kann ich kann sie nur theoretisch sagen du brauchst zwei
infrarot leds also du brauchst infrarot led du brauchst infrarot empfänger du
brauchst ein usb stecker du brauchst ein kabel mit wahrscheinlich sechs adern
oder so drin also im standard usb kabel ne was hat ein usb kabel usb kabel hat
vier ader so normales usb kabel plus minus zwei mal data usb 2.0 usb 2.0
kabel hat zwei hat vier ader
ja
ja aber usb 2 reicht so und da musst du das alles anlöten
wahrscheinlich auch ein paar widerstande an der richtigen stelle dabei aber da
gibt es da gibt es einen guide zu opto link bauen da gibt es einen guide zu
wie das geht mit schaltplan und was heißt schaltplan mit mit anleitung was
man was man braucht immer so ein opto link kabel selbst baut adapter
eigenbau genau alles klar alles klar für den elektrotechniker ist das
wahrscheinlich was ich hier sehe jetzt komplett für mich nicht alles klar ja
ja das läuft und wenn das der controller oder das hat auch mit dem
kabel gar nichts zu tun
ok ok es gibt ja aber wohl jede menge sachen
na zumindest ich habe ich habe noch ein kabel gekauft und gut ist und das hat
keine 70 euro gekostet und um das dann auszulesen brauchst du von
github hier so ist das das da brauchst du auf raspberry pi 0 wo das ding per usb
anschließt und damit kannst du dann den kram von erheizung auslesen es
funktioniert relativ gut
grafana ist easy musste nix großartig machen da kannst du alles im web front
zusammenklicken
fahner ist nicht schwierig
die 550 ja vor allem die china shops den haben nur fake bilder also warum
leider next cloud ja also ich bin kein großer next cloud fan die meisten
sachen die dabei sind wirken halt ultra halbbacken man muss sich mal die
notizapp angucken die glaube ich bis letzte next cloud version noch nicht
mal ordentlich notizen durchsuchen konnte also das ist halt echt lächerlich
man kann es für kalender und basic files und verwenden das ist auch das was ich
mache alles andere nervt mich einfach nur bei
next cloud oder wie würde man sagen plaudit
namen und adresse liegt ja erst erst dass das das in frankfurt genau besser
name so dass eindeutig hütsch liegt ich benutze ein i3 mega s 3d drugger so ein
teil fast wie 250 euro habe ich auch schon ein paar jahre ich sage dir
bescheid aber die müssen ja den kram erstmal verzollen wenn die das
geschafft haben dann geht es easy weiter zu mir aber die kriegen es ja nicht
gebacken
ja ich werde mir mal ein paar esp 32 stellen fit for fun dankeschön für den
sub excellent subscription hütsch ne das kann man nicht gescheit reparieren
vermute ich mal
ich wie gesagt also nach der erfahrung die ich jetzt mal wieder mit dhl express
gemacht haben und in den usa ich werde ich werde weiterhin china bestellen
und scheiß drauf dann türkisch größere gehäuse aus ist mir auch egal
china zeug alter ist beste ist billig kannst du gleich den zähler pack
bestellen und wenn es nicht geht ist auch nicht so wild gut du hast natürlich
das problem wie bei meinen spannungswandler finde den smoke clip jetzt
nicht wie bei den spannungswandler wenn es wenn das china zeug gar zu chinesisch
ist dann rauchzeit ab das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr
wie gesagt ist nicht angekommen
also das normale filament ist glaubt nicht so teuer oder also eine rolle
hält aber auch wirklich lang und bei den meisten 3d trocken ist eine rolle
filament dabei
hast du das nicht schon mal erzählt irgendjemand hat schon mal so was
gepostet so nach dem motto ich soll meinen 3d-drucker flaschen
ich bin ja ich bin ja immer für alles möglich zu haben den zu flaschen aber
der funktioniert echt nicht schlecht
da war ich schon mal früher
sein china crap steckt festes sagt
ja ich habe einfach mal random stream angemacht weil mich alles andere aufgeregt
hat habe ich immer wieder scheiß drauf mache ich jetzt stream mal und der chat der sorgt
dafür dass ich nicht mehr angepisst bin stimmts chat exzellent
ja spanien oder niederlande stimmt hast du eigentlich eine gute idee
ja das bringt ja aber auf ios nix das ist ja das problem wenn ich auf android bin
habe ich kein problem gucke ich von meinem amazon tablet ist das überhaupt
kein ding da habe ich auch keine werbung ich habe vor zwei tagen mal geguckt ich
kann sie gar nicht mehr sagen ich glaube es sind so sieben achttausend aufrufe täglich
henry 277 danke für den sub huge subscription wie heißt ein dark add-on dark reader
was die netgate ok das muss man kurz lesen leute die netgate jungs haben selbst
war implementiert und bsd den portbereich stellt der war ja gar entwickler selbst
hat sich angeschaut und diversen mugs entdeckt was in der bsd community dazu
geführt hat dass es nicht in der form für die wie von netgate entwickelt in
den korn eingebaut wurde netgate hat daraufhin die empfehlung gegeben war ja
erst doch nicht zu verwenden moment was ist für eine bescheuerte
empfehlung sie haben es doch ursprünglich verkackt und jetzt kann man
es nicht verwenden weil sie es verkackt haben big brain das so typische stonks
antwort wieder wo wir auch gerade bei stonks antworten sind leute ich muss mal
kurz unterbrechen den chat und zwar habt ihr das hicka habt ihr wahrscheinlich
habt ihr das hicka mitbekommen ob jetzt donnerstag feiertag ist oder nicht
meine fresse alda die richtig richtig 3 hat aktionen wieder hier am start und
jetzt war jetzt mal im ernste richtiger painstab also viel painstab
kann es echt nicht sein also mir persönlich ist es eigentlich
vollkommen egal ob das ein feiertag ist für corona oder ob das einfach nur frei
ist hauptsache feiertag ist mir wurscht das problem ist dass es jetzt noch nicht
mal ein feiertag ist es einfach gar nichts es ist einfach ganz normal und wir
haben dieses jahr guckt euch mal die feiertage dieses jahr an die sacken
mal richtig guckt euch das mal an
richtig massive krab hier schaut mal weihnachten fällt auf samstag sonntag
richter pains camp
nächstes jahr ist bei der wehr noch schlimmer nächstes jahr ist noch
schlimmer danach wird es wieder besser silvester ist freitag ja und das problem
ist dass das für eine beknackte seite alda ich will einfach nur die feiertage
sehen
was sind das für seiten ist das für eine seite die sieht aus wie 1995 das
hatten wir doch erst ach das ist zweit ärzthaft
ah ja badenwürtt hessen hessen
feiertage camp das wäre mal eine gute idee ich mache den feiertagen camp so
und und jetzt schreiben die keinen tag dabei alter was das ferien wiki das
klingt gut exzellent das ferien wiki also
genau es fällt eh schon total viel auf hännis doch gar kein feiertag
es ist ein feiertag
das wäre mir jetzt neu muttertag ist auch kein feiertag
ach in berlin echt ok habe ich gerade mitgekriegt dass in berlin feiertag ist
hey wäre ich mal in berlin ja wie bei wie beim grünen donnerstag wäre es auch
vollkommen egal ich sag nicht es kommen die ersten leute sagen wie der max sagt
es ist unsinnig mir ist es vollkommen egal warum den feiertag jetzt hauptsache
es ist ein feiertag die könnten auch feiertag machen für das spaghettimonster
oder für alle verkackten projekte der letzten jahre ist mir wurscht hauptsache
feiertag
ok alle bundesländer kann man auch können umstellen auf hessen vielleicht
hessen hessen hessen hessen hessen hessen camp ok also das dumme ist es
fällt auch prinzipiell immer viel auf montag und ihr wisst ja dass es für
mich besonders sagt wenn feiertage auf montag fallen und das schlimme ist
diese feiertage sind immer montags weil montags ist der tag in der woche wo ich
frei habe also wo ich arbeite nur noch vier tage die woche also sprich der tag
in der woche wo ich nicht arbeiten gehe und ich verschenke quasi immer zwei
feiertage durch mit den montag im jahr stelle euch das mal vor das ist ja nicht
auszuhalten first world problems extrem zumindest
dieses jahr sagt halt mal richtig sonntag samstag ist eh frei sonntag
donnerstag das ist das einzige was mir was bringt donnerstag bringt mir auch
was freitag neuer wait wait das ist das müll so und jetzt passt mal auf wenn ihr
denkt das war schon schlecht nächstes jahr ist noch x-fetel dankeschön für 21
monate subscriptions huge subs subscription excellent kannst du deinen freien tag auf
dienstag verschieben das müsste ich meinen chef mal fragen ich könnte ihn ja
mal fragen ob ich den 25.4 auf dienstag schieben kann und den 24.5 auf dienstag
ich habe montags leider handwerker besuch ich kann dann ich muss nee nee
moment umgedreht das funktioniert nicht ich habe das ich habe extra gesagt bin
fest montags nicht da wie hast du es geschafft nur vier tage zu arbeiten ich
krieg einfach weniger geld so und es passt mal auf 2022 ist richtiger pains
champ also 2022 ist für mich das beschissenste jahr was urlaub und feiertage
angeht überhaupt so weihnachts feiertag montag bringt mir nichts sonntag bringt
mir nichts montag bringt mir nichts donnerstag bringt mir was montag bringt
mir nichts donnerstag bringt was sonntag bringt mir nichts montag bringt mir
nichts freitag bringt mir was samstag bringt mich also von diesen feiertagen
bringt mir nur 1 2 3 feiertage was
pains champ oder was soll das nächstes jahr nächstes jahr wird es dann wieder
ein bisschen besser massiver pains champ aber ganz ganz ganz
ganz großer hütsch hütsch big thicc pains champ janr34 dankeschön für zwei
monat subscribtion ok chat weiter gucken ich hab ich hab sie ehrlich
wieder irgendwas vergessen aber
gibt es irgendeine vernünftige collab lösung wo du next laws features 5
jungs ich habe keine ahnung ich würde ich würde in den riesen bogen drum
machen der irgendwie collaboration über next cloud zu machen
next cloud funktioniert ja schon die normalen sachen hat richtig
irgendwelche collaboration sachen
oder meinst du eine andere lösung die nicht next cloud ist die das kann was
du mit next cloud machst g style 90 twitch prime gaming hütsch acht
monate hyper fast fast fast hyper subscribtion aber noch ist es noch nur
nur normaler
das ding habe ich doch auch oder ach nee nee moment mal ich hab mich
verguckt aber was das zeig mal ja
wie schließt man da was an
wie soll das funktionieren
ach du schließt da drüber dein gerät an und ermisst dann was dieses eine
gerät verbraucht naja gut das bringt mir ja nix ich ich ich lese ja unten im
keller das komplette das den strom zähler fürs komplette haus ab
haben wir ein ubiquity türklingel gekauft halte nichts von dem ring ja
erhör mal auf also ring ist ja wirklich massive pains gem genau dieses andere
diesen ganzen anderen graben sind da gibt alles müll ich sehe es auch nicht ein mal
ganz im ernst ich sehe es auch nicht ein ein abo abzuschließen für meine
türklingel ich will den türk ein abo dass ich naja ok man darf hier seine
türklingel auch so verwenden aber dass man irgendwelche sachen speichern kann
ich mein wenn ein abo für eine türklingel dass ich schon mal echt
das muss man jetzt mal gucken was man da was man als alles drinne kriegen
saurus master da ich für den zapp so aber das ist das ist das ist echt die
pest gerade du aber für die türklingel aber für die security kamera aber für
das thermostat leute oder oder oder irgendwie google service für das
thermostat ist es ist letztens als ich glaube als aws probleme hat da konnten
manche leute jetzt messbar zu wahrscheinlich nicht betroffen als die
als aws letztens probleme hat konnten leute die heizung nicht mehr anmachen
weil es über die cloud ging das muss man sich mal vorstellen
lasst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen es gibt leute die können ihre
heizung nicht die müssen sich quasi den hinteren abfrieren weil die cloud nicht
geht und ihre heizung nicht mehr regeln können
das ist also 2021 ist echt wir was das angeht ja
deswegen also wer sowas macht ist nicht mehr ganz dicht ihr wisst ich bin ja ein
ein heim automatisierungs fern und ich habe auch relativ viel am start aber ich
sehe es nicht ein auf internetverbindung angewiesen zu sein plus den cloud
service der verfügbar sein muss dass ich dass ich einfachste dinger bei mir
daheim machen kann max machst du viel an der arbeit
ne gar nicht wir machen zum größten teil puppet leider ich werde ein simple
auch schöner ok also was kriegt man denn hierfür das computer bild
eine klingel das ist eine türklingel ok protect pläne heißt das anscheinend ok
was ein schwachsinn sag mal kann ich das kann ich wenigstens die reine klingel
funktion verwenden wenn ich kein abo habe ohne kosten enthalten ok zwei
jahre eingeschränkte garantie das klingt ja schon mal wie den super super deal
ja man davon abgesehen gesetzliche gewährleistung müssen die liefern das
bedauert das bedeutet sechs monate ist eh schon mal gar keine gar kein thema
und die nächste zeit eigentlich meistens auch nicht echt seit wie die hoh ich
kann die kamera verwenden die ich gekauft habe umsonst kosten ohne
zusätzliche koste ich kann quasi kostenlos für das was ich mir gekauft
habe das verwenden ok also die absoluten basic funktionen gehen auch ohne abo
na ok das heißt man braucht man braucht es nicht wirklich aber so ein video
verlauf ist schon nett wenn man denn so was hat aber mittlerweile es will echt
jeder für alles in den abo haben vom game pass wusste dass sogar ubisoft in
gelben pass hat ubisoft plus heißt das bei den beiden was macht eigentlich
stadia gerade so habt ihr gerade gesehen was das auto vervollständigt hat
stadia negativ latency also entweder entweder ist das besonders clever was ich
immer suche oder es haben wirklich noch mehr leute nach negativ latency
gekocht das eiken sagt ist er echt was war big brain
tatsächlich das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen dass die eiken sich da
vorne unterscheiden chat habt ihr das schon mal gesehen
das kommt aus der history und das sind google ergebnisse soll ich das schon mal
aufgefallen dass das von der eiken vorne anders ist
das weiß doch jeder echt mir ist das noch nie aufgefallen
ihr sagt jetzt alle nur ja genau ubisoft hat auch so ein dolles aber
kostet 15 euro im monat 15 euro im monat wollen die age 69
15 euro
da musste schon großer ubisoft fern sein dass ich das lohnt
das kann man sich vielleicht mal für zwei monate holen wenn man irgendwie
letzten 20 assassins creed nachholen will oder so der game pass den finde ich
tatsächlich ganz nice ja hat ubisoft überhaupt so viele gute spiele das ist
eine berechtigte frage kommt mal so was so was mag ich übrigens auf
webseiten auch nicht wenn es aussieht wie den link aber es ist dann kein link
also für watchdog legion werde ich mir das garantiert nicht kaufen watchdog
legion ist ein richtiges pains gemp game allein schon wenn ich mir dieses möchte
gern hipster hacker szenario angucke ok was ist da irgendwas gescheites dabei
ubisoft
gut uno euer da habe ich drauf gewartet
es sind schon paar gute sachen dabei aber ich bezweifle es doch stark dass
ich das in irgendeine art und weise lohnt 15 euro im monat dafür auszugeben
die spekulieren natürlich drauf wie alle dass man das verlängert und oder
vergisst wenn man sich einmal oder einmal oder zweimal kauft das sind auch
diese ganzen es heißt im schritt mobile games sind am start wenn man sich das
einmal kauft oder zweimal und einfach alles am stück durchspielt was die
haben ok aber man muss auch dazu sagen die meisten sachen hat man die meisten
guten sachen hat man ja eh schon gespielt also ich finde das lohnt sich
nicht wisst ihr was wisst ihr was noch schlimmer als endlich scroll ist gar
kein scroll und man muss immer auf mehr anzeigen klicken alternativ leute ich
ich hätte da ich hätte dann vorschlag ich weiß der ist old school ich weiß
er ist richtig old school aber wie wäre es einfach mit 100 100 spiele laden
und uns kräumen machen ich mein 100 100 100 solcher dinger das macht jetzt mein
rechner auch nicht kaputt vielleicht wirkt ich mein das guckt euch mal an
das konnte man nicht auf einmal laden das geht nicht undenkbar undenkbar dass
auf einmal zu laden oder durch die seiten zwitschen ja
also das panzer general 2 das ist von 1999 oder sowas das ist alt das kann ich
daran erinnern das stand mal in der games da drin wo ich früher noch ja das
sieht auch so aus das stand also schon in games da aber hatte war das in der
games da drin 97 da fack
das super werbung für ubisoft plus
läuft das spiel das ist gute frage läuft das noch systemanforderungen xp
vis da ja anscheinend anscheinend läuft das läuft das wieder weil moment warum
muss das direkt x9 kompatibel sein das ist ein spiel von 97 da ist mit direkt
x gar nichts das ist 2d software händler
1,4 gigahertz what the fack achte in dem launcher
das ist das der ubisoft launcher funktioniert wahrscheinlich
guck wann grafikan wieder zu bezahlbaren preisen kommen also ich habe ja mal in
die glaskugel gucken habe gesagt im sommer das problem ist nur es ist jetzt
fast schon april da fehlt nicht mehr viel bis sommer und es sieht aktuell nicht
so aus
chinesische energie genau vollkommen nicht pro tier 1 13 monat huge
hyper subscription dankeschön für den zapp so sieht es aus kio kun
bringt das wirklich was ich meine der drucker kann er nur so schnell fahren
wieder 3d drucker fahren kann also ich frage mich ernsthaft wie wie wie wie
holt eine steuerung über den 3d für mit dem raspberry pi den trepp ein 3d
drucker eine stunde druckzeit raus was man nicht auch so über octopi oder so
konfigurieren könnte was macht er also überspringt er
verschiedene sachen oder frage ich mich echt wie soll das funktionieren ja ja
das haben wir schon gesehen deswegen werde ich kein china kram
bei den chinesen bestellen
echt das finde ich okay das ist nice immer mehr feiertage wenn es nach mir
geht können die jeden zweiten feiertag man pätel dankeschön für den zapp 21
monat ich weiß nicht ob ich schon los vorgelesen aber 21 ist ja das ist ja
quasi triple hyper subscriber
so mehr geht jetzt nicht macht man finger nicht mit das sollte man
tatsächlich mal machen das sollte man tatsächlich mal machen für alle leute
die nachweislich 30 90 preordert haben und noch nicht bekommen haben sollte es
eigentlich ein gratis feiertag geben das ist eine gute idee
bekommst du nicht die feiertage anteilig angerechnet an die arbeitszeit
wer bekommt feiertage an die arbeitszeit angerechnet ich meine
hätte ich auch gerne aber feiertage ist feiertage
du meinst jetzt bei mir wegen den vier tagen also das sollte man aber machen da
gebe ich dir recht mein chef hat mir letztens erzählt er hat letztens in
mann stream reingekuckt falls er jetzt auch gerade zuguckt wir
sollten unbedingt feiertage an meine arbeitszeit anrechnet man bekommt den
tag doch eh gut geschrieben lull was
die was nein ich bekomme nichts gut geschrieben
vier tage ist hier auch die leute da wollte ich ihnen video drüber machen das
mache ich mache ich glaube ich als nächstes an freitag oder so so die
beste entscheidung meines lebens oder so nenne ich das video mal gucken aber
jetzt mal ohne miss vier tage zu arbeiten war eines der besten sachen wie
ist das genau wollte ich mich gleich noch was zu erzählen die also vier tage zu
arbeiten das war wirklich eines der besten entscheidungen ich je getroffen
habe und es gibt ja dazu ein paar regeln wenn ihr das auch machen wollt also wie
gesagt ich persönlich kann es euch nur empfehlen
ihr verdient natürlich vereinfacht gesagt 20 prozent weniger geld es ist
nicht ganz 20 prozent weniger es sind 17 halb prozent oder so aber insgesamt
verdient natürlich weniger aber ich finde nachdem eh niemand sagt fack ich
wenn er abkratzt fack ich hätte mal mehr arbeiten sollen wenn euch die
kohle irgendwie ausreicht ja und wenn ihr so seid wie ich was das angeht und ihr
nicht irgendwie so den klassischen karriere crime machen wollt in so einer
oldschool firma wo man karriere dadurch macht dass man immer präsent ist zu
allem seinen senf dazu gibt und am besten wenn der wenn der abteilungsleiter
fragt der erste seit er sagt leute hier ich mache das ich habe eine super idee
und und sonst wie also dass sie baro ist am start cute mod himself
du bist heute out of order hat hat das was mit dem mit dem lehramt grill zu tun
zumindest eine sache ich auch fertig sagen wollte also also vom genau also
wenn wenn ihr mit der kohle auskommt und ihr nicht zu den ultra klassischen
karriere crime in so einer oldschool firma machen wollt kann ich euch nur
empfehlen versucht teilzeit zu arbeiten das ist das beste was ihr machen könnt
normalerweise ist es doch so wenn wochenende ist ihr könnt ja mal sagen wie
es euch dabei geht ja aber ich kann euch mal sagen wie es mir dabei gegangen ist
also wenn du freitags gearbeitet hast bist du eigentlich kaputt du willst
dann freitag nicht mehr großartig was machen es sei denn du bist erst 20 und
hast noch so viel energie dass du freitags dann voll abgehst noch ok alles
klar also freitags machst du eh schon immer viel samstag schläft aus samstag
machst du quasi nach dem ausschlafen mal einen tag die sachen die du die ganze
woche erledigen musstest oder irgendwas was unbedingt gemacht werden muss machst
du samstag und dann hast du so ab samstag nachmittag hast du dann zeit oder
oder je nachdem samstag tag über verteilt komplett das zu machen was du
willst da kannst du sonntags ausschlafen oder kannst du sonntag noch mal zum
größten teil machen was du willst was aber auch nicht geht weil es sonntag ist
so und sonntag ab 16 uhr denkst du eigentlich schon immer am ist
muss man schon mal gedanken machen morgen muss ja wieder auf die arbeit und das
sagt du hast am wochenende unterm strich eigentlich nur eineinhalb tage wirklich
frei oder wirklich erholung oder es haben wir mal eins bis eineinhalb tage
maximal am wochenende erholung und wenn ihr einen tag mehr frei habt am besten
natürlich dann entweder freitag oder montag dass es am stück ist es kommt
euch deutlich mehr vor als nur einen tag mehr es kommt euch ehrlich gesagt eher
so vor als habt ihr dann wirklich volle drei tage erholung gehabt als nur eins
bis eineinhalb obwohl es nur einen tag mehr ist kann man schwer erklären aber
so so ging es mir und ich glaube so geht es geht es einigen anderen auch noch
ja janr64 habe ich schon vorgelesen trotzdem noch was danke für den sub
es war schon drei monate huge subscriptions ja nice schön dass du hierher gefunden hast
wenn du jetzt noch youtube überreden kannst dass meine videos wieder
empfohlen werden bin ich dabei dann darfst du hier bleiben
nein nein quatsch darfst auch so da bleiben natürlich freue mich über jenen
der sein wich hierher findet ach so okay
roll immer ein bisschen schneller ist echt so kannst du easy
Ja, Linus kann auch nicht hell sein, aber ja ich denke auch im Sommer ist noch ein bisschen
zu früh.
Tja, ich hab gelesen, man kann sich einen Flug nach Russland buchen und sich da impfen
lassen von den Cacomods.
Das DAL Video hab ich gelöscht.
Oh, Pogas de Barro.
Schlafen ist das beste an Homeoffice, ist so.
Aha, wow, keine Ahnung, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, bin ich, passt, ist gut der 3D-Trocker.
Ich glaube, das kann man jetzt auch falsch verstehen, so für die Leute, die arbeiten
im Homeoffice weniger, aber was du meinst, ist, wie geil das ist, wenn man dadurch mehr
Zeit hat.
Ja, ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass viele Leute, die jetzt lange Homeoffice hatten,
gar keinen Bock mehr haben normal zu arbeiten.
Und wo bestellt Banggood jetzt hier oder auf deren Webseite?
Was?
Banggood?
Banggood kriegt es direkt von den Herstellern, die sitzen ja da irgendwo in China.
Oder war Banggood in Indien?
Nee, ich glaube auch in China.
Was?
Du hast deinen Job verloren, weil du 10 Jahre zu jung bist, was ist das für eine bescheuerte
Begründung?
Das klingt, ehrlich gesagt, klingt als vorgeschoben.
Predicte ich jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, wie das...
Willkommen in der Welt des Game Streamings, also wenn du nicht gerade Google Stadia hast
mit negativer Tense, dann wird das nichts.
Also Game Streaming und Lack geben sich so die Klinke in die Hand so.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe auch schon Game Streaming benutzt mit meiner Grafikkarte zum
Shield Tablet, das steht aber genau zwei Meter hinter der Wand im anderen Zimmer.
Das ging eigentlich, aber da habe ich auch mit dem Controller gespielt.
Ich habe es mit Default Settings probiert, aber mir ist klar, dass ich mit Custom Settings
und Tuning da noch einiges rausholen könnte.
Deswegen frage ich mich halt, was so eine Custom Firmware bringen soll, weil die Geschwindigkeit
und so, das kann ich ja auch so alles einstellen.
Ist Bang oder das, neben das, wo es verfügbar ist und am billigsten, was du brauchst?
Was hat nach einem ordentlichen Grundgefang mehr, als das, wo du mir nicht gesagt hast,
ok, Spastenladen?
Ich kenne den Laden zwar nicht, aber das ist richtig stumm.
Je nachdem, was du für einen Vertrag bei denen hast, kannst du denen auch das Leben schwer
machen.
Ich meine, arbeiten würde ich da eh nicht mehr, aber du kannst denen das Leben schwer
machen, dass du vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Abfindungen bekommst oder einfach die
abfacken kannst.
Alter ist definitiv kein Grund jemanden rauszuschmeißen und wenn das einer sagt, ist das sicherlich
auch diskriminierend und verstößt gegen Dinger, frag mir nicht.
Hast du Lust für unsere Webseite ein Tool zu programmieren, welches eine Spiele-Liste
mit Informationen zur Barrierefreiheit anzeigt plus neue Einträge zugefügt?
Klar, klar, was kriege ich dafür?
Ich meine, man muss gucken, wo man bleibt, richtig, richtig, also das ist genau so, wie
wenn, es ist ja mittlerweile sogar so, wenn du Bewerber bist und du wirst abgelehnt aus
diesen Gründen, kannst du dich schon verklagen.
Es gab sogar ein paar Prozesse, da wurden Leute abgelehnt, keine Ahnung, weil sie zu
alt, zu jung, zu weiblich, zu schwarz oder zu sonst was sind und die haben danach den
potenziellen Arbeitgeber verklagt und die mussten dann teilweise sogar noch zwei, drei
Monatsgehälter bezahlen, an jemanden, den sie noch nie angestellt hatten, weil das nicht
okay war.
Die wollten meinen Vertrag nicht verlängern, na gut, wenn der Vertrag ausgelaufen ist,
kannst du da eh nicht viel machen, aber die Aussage, altermäßig, könntest du sie auf
jeden Fall, wenn du sie abfacken willst, abfacken, da der Pi den G-Code schneller verarbeiten
kann als der Drucker, echt, ist das das Bottleneck, ich dachte immer, die Geschwindigkeit von
meinem 3D-Drucker ist das Problem, also ich meine, die physische Geschwindigkeit von
meinem 3D-Drucker ist das Problem, nicht so sehr, wie schnell da irgendwo was verarbeitet
werden kann, aber okay, aber dass man 30% schneller rausholt, das erscheint mir trotzdem relativ
viel.
Sebaru, lege dich hin, lege dich hin und geh auf euren Weebspam-Discord.
So, okay, jetzt hab ich das, ich hab endlich den Chat aufgeholt, würdest du einen Unify-Router
empfehlen?
Du meinst einen Unify-Router?
Nö, würd ich nicht.
Habe ich mal das Rebstockbad auf, würde ich nicht, hab ich selbst keine Erfahrung mit
und hat mich jetzt auch nicht, irgendwie angesprochen, ja, weiß nicht, dass es schlecht ist, aber
hat mich nicht angesprochen.
Oh, Flashbang, ich muss was anderes aufmachen, wo nicht so geflashbangt wird, äh, Moment.
Ah, yes, gleich viel besser, außer das Bild, ähm, ich hab mir noch was aufgeschrieben,
was ich erzählen wollte, wo hab ich das denn?
Ja, also Leute, ich hab ja jetzt die letzten paar Tage weniger gestreamt und ich muss echt
sagen, ich vermisse, ich vermisse, dass abends dann, also ich denke, ich hab was verpasst
und hab was nicht gemacht, wenn ich nicht gestreamt hab, ist komisch, ich hab mir wie
gesagt letzten Tage bisschen gebastelt hier, da war ich abends beschäftigt, aber, äh,
ist echt geil, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt einfach mal streamen an und
scheiß drauf, ich hab heut kein großartiges Thema, wie ihr vielleicht schon gemerkt
habt.
Was hältst du von diesem Werbebild, der Telekom 5k, was seh ich da, das sieht wir aus, das
ist ne Drohne, das da ist ein Flugzeug oder so, keine Ahnung, wie kommst du da drauf,
hast du das Bild gemacht?
Und willst, dass ich was zu deinen Grafik-Skills sage oder was, das ist ne 5k Marketing-Bild,
das ist ein Auto, das sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen Rohre, das erkenne ich nicht und
das ist irgendeine, so ne Drohne mit Kamera oder, ah Moment, Moment, das ist ne Drohne
mit Sitzplätzen drinnen, ok, ok, Moment, Moment, Telekom, das wirds so nicht geben,
zumindest nicht bei uns und, ähm, also ich weiß, dass es sowas prinzipiell schon gibt,
aber das wirds bei uns so nicht geben und man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen, ob das jetzt
so das Aushängeschild von 5g ist, weiß ich nicht, wisst ihr was ein richtig geiles Aushängeschild
von 5g wär, meine flächendeckende Abdeckung mit 5g und nicht wie früher, war mein Tal
am Bahnhof immer komplett, wie nennt man es, Punktloch, ja, komplett Internet-Abriss,
ähm, ich kann, also ich mach jetzt seit ungefähr ziemlich genau nem Jahr Homeoffice, so, das
heißt irgendwann im März 2020, weiß ich noch, gabs diese Besprechung, wo es bei uns
im Team drum ging, so wir machen ab jetzt nur noch Homeoffice und ich war grad am Bahnhof
als die Besprechung stattgefunden hat und hab mich im Zug gesetzt und ich hatte vier
oder fünf komplette Disconnects auf der Fahrt und hab die Hälfte nicht mitgekriegt, richtig
fürn Arsch, ja, Industrie 4.0, hey ich hab lustigerweise heut mit einem auf der Arbeit
gelabert und er hat auch was von Industrie 4.0 erzählt und da hab ich gefragt, ja, was
genau versteht man eigentlich unter Industrie 4.0, wusste auch nicht, ihr scheint das zu
wissen, Chat, was genau versteht man unter Industrie 4.0, einfach nur besonders Big Brain
Industrie, da hast du recht, ich würd auch mit keiner bemannten Telekom Drohne fliegen,
ne, im Leben nicht, wobei, was ich geil fände, wenn Amazon per Drohne liefert,
auf der Insel 5G gehabt, ja, nice, am See, da ist auch nix drum herum,
Dongs Begriff, Big Data, Blockchain, im Zweifelsfall, also wenn man anfängt und sagt Digitalisierung,
Big Data, dann muss man auch noch einfach mal Blockchain sagen, hat nicht unbedingt
was damit zu tun, aber klingt immer gut, Predictive Maintenance, ist Predictive Maintenance diese
Geschichten, wenn das Auto beim Parken Firmware Update macht und dann nicht mal losfährt,
gab's ja schon genug Beispiele zu, Blockchain ist wieder out, was, wie, nein, Blockchain
ist nicht out, wir machen jetzt einen Impfpass mit Blockchain, wusstet ihr das noch nicht,
wir machen jetzt Impfpass mit Blockchain gegen Corona, wer sich fragt, was hat das alles
miteinander zu tun, ich weiß es auch nicht, excellent Musik, Industrie sagt keiner weiß,
was das ist, ja, ist wahrscheinlich echt so, also wenn du wirklich ernsthaft willst,
dann kannst du das machen, ich bin kein Webentwickler, muss ich gleich dazu sagen, ich mach zwar
ab und zu hier ein bisschen Webentwicklung, aber ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Webentwickler,
das Problem beim Glasfaserausbau ist, dass es einen riesen Stau gibt und dass das irgendwie
total ineffizient ist, die machen dann so Dinge wie, erstmal abstimmen, in einem Dorf
wo 80% Rentner wohnen, Rentner wollt ihr Glasfaser, das kostet dann 5 Euro mehr und dann kommen
dann die Rentner an und sagen, was ist das für neumotische Scheiß, das braucht doch
keiner und dann soll ich auch noch mehr für den, für bezahle, nee, nee, nee, lass mal
gut sein, so und dann gibt es das nicht, oder aber es hat vor zwei Wochen jemand ausgebaut
und dann bauen sie nochmal aus und nochmal oder sie bauen nie aus, weil sie ja vor zwei
Wochen schon aus, es ist für wir mit dem Ausbau, übrigens habt ihr es gelesen, Leute ihr hättet
es nicht für möglich gehalten, wo ist die News, hättet ihr das für möglich gehalten,
also ich war fest der Überzeugung, dieses Jahr klappt es und jetzt klappt es wieder
nicht, damit hätte ich nie gerechnet Leute, ihr sicherlich auch nicht, das ist das erste
mal, dass es nicht klappt ja, es hat immer geklappt bisher, so fail, so fail, ich kann
dazu gar nichts mehr sagen, ich mein ich hab jetzt schon bestimmt fünf Videos gemacht
in den letzten Jahren zu diesem Thema und im Prinzip sag ich, ich mein ich mach das
seit zehn Jahren schon, nee Leute ich mach wahrscheinlich jedes Jahr ein Video drüber,
ich hab zehn Jahre YouTube und ich hab bestimmt schon zehn Videos zu dem Thema gemacht und
ich sage im Endeffekt mehr oder weniger in jedem Video das gleiche, weil es auch der
gleiche Scheiß ist seit zehn Jahren, klar es ist schon in manchen Bereichen besser geworden,
das wäre auch ein Witz wenn nicht, aber im Vergleich zur restlichen Welt wird es eigentlich
immer schlechter bei uns, vergleichsweise, also wenn man sich mal mit anderen da misst,
echt fail, mega fail, meinst du es wäre sicher ein Web Server wie Nextcloud ins Internet
zu stellen, aber mit HTTPS Endpoint nur eigensigniert als ja, allerdings würde ich das nicht Nextcloud
machen, sondern ich würde noch irgendeinen Reverseproxy dazwischen machen, dann ist das
sicher ja, so sicher wie es halt sein kann, das ist ok, also gerade wenn du kleinen Zertifikate
verwendest und es ordentlich gemacht hast, dann ist das sicher, aber dann kannst du
einfach einen VPN nehmen oder, machts vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher, frag mich was zu
Glasfaser und 5G, ja, wann wird bei mir ausgebaut, mir fällt jetzt so spontan nichts ein, aber
wenn du wirklich Bock hast über das, also wenn du bei der Telekom warst und echt Bock
hast über das Thema zu reden, könnte man da fast ein Video machen, sofern du da öffentlich
was zu sein hast, da gibt es bestimmt viele spannende Sachen.
So, super, super, ja, Bürokratie können wir gut.
Oh, was ist hier los, was, bei uns haben die Leute gefordert, das ist das Telefonbuch,
was wir digitalisieren, ok, als geil, achso bei euch irgendwie intern, wo man dann Leute
suchen kann, was hat der Max für eine interne Telefonnummer, als geile Node.js Anwendung
mit einem Pretty Web Interface, doch bitte auch als druckbare Version zur Verfügung
zu stellen, der kann doch einfach das alte weiternehmen, gedruckte Version, das sieht
man mal wie hängen geblieben manche Leute sind, aber ich hoffe ihr habt das auch agil
entwickelt mit Daily Scrums, ansonsten kann die Anwendung ja nichts geworden sein, sind
wir uns ja einig oder, und das Kanban Board musste geupdatet werden, schön, Kanban Board
dürft ihr meinetwegen auch per Sticker an der Tafel machen, das ist auch ok, weil das
ist agil, egal ob an der Tafel oder im Ticketsystem, Scrum im öffentlichen Dienst, ja ohne Scrum
nicht agil, agile und diagonal skalieren mit Blockchain, der Impfpass, wie hoch schätzte
die Chancen ein, dass ein europäischer Impfpass bis Mitte des Jahres da ist und dass es technisch
gut umgesetzt ist, also für mich geht das gegen Null, wenn man das mit anderen IT Projekten
vergleicht, die wir so verkackt haben schon, also vorher haben wir Gigabit für alle, ich
immer, was ist denn eine Endpoint Protection für dich, sowas wie Reverse Proxy davor stellen
mit irgendeiner Authentifizierung bevor man aus Webinterface kommt oder wie oder was, ganz
ehrlich die beste Windows Protection ist eine Linux Kiste davor, so doofs klingt, aber wenn
die Windows Kiste ans Internet soll ist das echt das beste was du machen kannst, wieso
weißt du nicht Max FPS, weil ich den Twitch Account erstellt habe, wovor ich wusste dass
ich selbst streamen will, na günstig, günstig wird der Impfpass garantiert, na das können
wir uns schon mal abschminken, ich mein die müssen sich erst mal 50 Beraterfirmen holen
die sie beraten dafür, allein schon die werden teuer, das ist eine gute Idee, also wenn du
echt Bock drauf hast, könntest du dich an meine Business E-Mail wenden und mir einen
Discord Kontakt oder so zu kommen lassen, die findest du hier auf YouTube im hier, also
wenn du eingeloggt bist kannst du hier drauf klicken und dann siehst du die E-Mail Adresse,
das wäre echt geil, wenn ich mal ein Video mit einem von der Telekom über Telekom Sachen
machen könnte, ja, wir werden nichts internes erzählen, wir wollen ja nicht dass du Probleme
kriegst, aber mit Sachen die verfügbar sind und deinem Einblick dazu, das könnte tatsächlich
eine gute Sache sein, ja, okay das ist ein Problem unter iOS ja auch, ja, hallo Max was
ist deine Meinung zu Pepega, ich benutze lieber Pepega Aim, darf man dir eigentlich Webprojekte
vergleichweise deine Preischamp vorstellen, du kannst hier links zu GitHub Sachen und
so posten, ja, übrigens Windows Defender, Leute soll ich euch mal den Hammer erzählen,
den wirklich den Windows Hammer schlechthin, das ist echt also, also Windows Defender heißt
ja nicht mal Windows Defender, sondern das heißt Microsoft, jetzt dürft ihr mal mit
mir ne Runde kecken, Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection heißt das und das gibt es auch
für Linux und wir haben auf der Arbeit die Ehre, dass man, dass wir auf Linux System
mittlerweile auf den einen Linux System haben wir die große Ehre, dass wir Microsoft Defender
Advanced Threat Protection installieren mussten, weil sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
sind, sie holen sich irgendwie Consultants von Microsoft und die Consultants von Microsoft
haben gesagt, damit man sie ordentlich konsultieren kann und ihre Arbeit machen können als Consultants
muss man als erstes mal den Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection installieren, also was das
gekostet hat, zumindest wir haben Linux Kisten mit Microsoft Defender drauf und jetzt kommt
der Hammer, was wir rausgekriegt haben ist, das Ding lockt, obwohl es ausgeschaltet ist,
also wir haben es nur in diesem, nicht so nur in diesem Logging oder wie heißt das,
in diesem Halbaus Passiv Modus, der verbraucht teilweise 60% CPU auf den Kisten, 60%, wir
mussten manche VMs schon upgraden, weil der Windows Defender die dicht gemacht hat, waren
zum Glück VMs, in Azure ist das ganze noch besser, in Azure kriegt dann Microsoft direkt
Geld dafür, so aber jetzt kommt der Hammer, jetzt kommt der Hammer, der lockt jegliche,
ohne dass uns das jemand mitgeteilt hat, ich bin mir sicher, dass das Datenschutz technisch
überhaupt nicht erlaubt ist und ansonsten musst du auch wegen jedem Furz zum Betriebsrad
rennen und das geht jetzt einfach oder wie, zumindest wir haben mitbekommen, dass das Ding
jegliche Shell Eingabe auf dem System lockt, das haben wir rausbekommen, weil jemand hat
die Locks durchsucht und hat sein Passwort gefunden, ernsthaft, das ist kein Witz, das
ist kein Witz, der ist in diesen Lock Explorer oder was das war, reingegangen hat es gesucht,
der hat sein Passwort gefunden, das ist ein Keylogger, im Endeffekt, ein 2-Fetch Keylogger,
das ist den ja in Ernst, doch und wisst ihr was mich noch mehr schockiert, das haben wir
heute auf unserer Teamrunde besprochen, außer 3 Leute oder so, es hat keinen gejuckt, wie
lange ist das her, heute, seit der letzten Version macht er das, es hat keinen gejuckt,
ich hab auch gemeint, ey vielleicht verkopie-paste man sich mal und möchte nicht unbedingt,
dass alles an Microsoft geschickt wird, echt der Wahnsinn, ich glaube, das ist vielen gar
nicht klar dort, weil wie gesagt, ansonsten musst du wegen jedem Scheiß zum Betriebsrat
oder irgendwie dir das 50.000 mal von der Rechtsabteilung absegeln lassen, wenn du was
machst, was meint ihr, was das für ein Akt ist, ich krieg das bei unserem Support immer
mit, bei unserem Support kommen manchmal Leute und sagen, oh ich hab meine Mail gelöscht,
was soll ich denn hier herstellen, wisst ihr Datenschutzbeauftragte, das ist echt eine
gute Idee, so was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen, ja wie gesagt, du musst wegen jedem Furz sonst
dahin und dir das absignen lassen und wenn die bei uns genau, wie gesagt, ich krieg das
ja beim Support mit und wenn die Mails wieder herstellen sollen, das ist ein riesen Akt
mit Einwilligungen holen und hin und her, also sprich, es meldet sich einer vom Außendienst
und sagt, hui ich hab meine Mail gelöscht und dann kannst du nicht einfach in die Backups
gehen und die Mail wieder herstellen, weil da könntest du die Mail ja lesen, da musst
du erstmal eine riesige Genehmigung müssen die sich einholen, dass sie die Mail wieder
herstellen dürfen, wenn du dich jetzt aber einmal aus versehen verkopie paste, das ist
die gesamte Mail bei Microsoft gespeichert, ich glaube nicht, dass das so Sinn und Zweck
der Übung ist, haben wir einen Sicherheitsbeauftragten, ja ihr bringt mich da gerade auf eine Idee,
aber ehrlich gesagt, das mach ich nicht, ohne dass ich meinen Chef mal angehauen hab,
ich will den Leuten ja irgendwie nix reinwürgen und im Zweifelsfall kriegt er dann auch irgendwelche
Probleme, aber ihr bringt mich da echt auf eine gute Idee, ja, was schon gesehen, Ausweispflicht
für WhatsApp, was, alter welche uralt pepega Opas haben sich das denn wieder ausgedacht,
das muss ich jetzt mal kurz, das geht schnell und das meiste kann man skippen bei den Videos,
das muss ich mal kurz geben, ja das Seehofer erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, das ist
ja auch nicht umsetzbar letztendlich, die haben immer, wie kommen die immer auf so Ideen,
auf solche Ideen, bevor die laufen, irgendwelche Leute und Dienst abfacken, sollten sie doch
mal gucken, dass die hauptsächlich mal ihre eigenen IT-Projekte ordentlich hinbekommen,
ja, die haben wieder Übelste da schon, wie weltfremd kann man eigentlich sein, ja.
okay, zeige ich mal her, das hat er mittlerweile drauf, den Abos sehr laut,
die hatten doch letztens vor ein paar Jahren auch sowas wie Klar-Namen-Flicht auf Facebook,
Klar-Namen-Flicht im Kommentarbereich, echt lächerlich mittlerweile, na gut, wisst ihr
woran das, worauf das rauslaufen wird, dass dann keiner mehr offiziell die Sachen in
Deutschland anbietet und keiner mehr zu Diensten in Deutschland geht, Telekommunikationsgesetz,
also man plant eine Überarbeitung unseres Telekommunikationsgesetzes und da ist geplant,
nach Meinung von CSU-Innenminister Horst Seehofer, dass man doch bitte schön künftig seinen
Ausweis zeigt, wenn man so ein WhatsApp-Account registriert, das gilt aber nicht nur für
WhatsApp, sondern auch für E-Mail-Anbieter und möglicherweise auch noch für alle anderen
Messenger-Dienste, da könnte man auch noch an Facebook-Messenger und so weiter erdenken,
immer dann, wenn man sich bei einem Telekommunikationsdienst anmeldet, möchte das Unternehmen doch verpflichtet
werden, Name, Geburtsdatum, Adresse und so weiter zu überprüfen, warum, sind, ich weiß
gar nicht, also ich möchte mal eine Sache jetzt sagen, warum ich das, also der hauptsächliche
Punkt, warum wir solche Forderungen auf den Sack legen, es gibt viele Punkte, aber der
hauptsächliche Punkt, der hauptsächliche Punkt ist, dass freie Meinungsäußerung ein
gewissen, vor allem wenn man was kritisches äußern will, ein gewisses Maß an Anonymität,
weil wenn man was leaken will, ein gewisses Maß an Anonymität erfordert, das geht einfach
nicht anders.
Also wenn du kritische Sachen sagen möchtest, wir reden nicht von illegalen Sachen, von
kritischen Sachen, die vielleicht vielen Leuten nicht gefallen, dann musst du das sagen können
im Internet, ohne, dass morgen dein Auto kaputt ist, und das ist das, was mich bei dieser Sache
am allermeisten aufregt, dass da irgendwie keiner dran denkt.
Wer kennt noch D-Mail, ich kenne sogar noch den E-Postbrief, da war mal einer von meinen
Arbeitskollegen, zwei von meinen Arbeitskollegen waren mal bei D-Mail und E-Postbrief oder
wie das heißt, ja und die haben da ganz viele tolle Sachen von erzählt.
Ja und der Personalausweis wäre dazu zu prädestiniert, es ist halt nicht gesagt, dass das der Personalausweis
sein soll, aber es müssen sozusagen die Adressdaten überprüft werden, ja nicht schön, da geben
wir noch mehr Daten ehrlicherweise an die Social Networks, ich hatte mich ja gefreut, dass
ich nochmal irgendwo einen Account ohne alle meine vollen Daten angeben muss, aber da ist
ja jetzt noch mal eine ganze Menge mehr geplant, logisch, womit das begründet wird, ihr ahnt
es, dreimal dürft ihr raten, Verfolgung von Straftaten, klar kommt von unserem Innenminister,
das erfordert, dass man die Anonymität von Personen aufhebt.
Ja, wenn du den eigenen Messenger betreibst, dann musst du dir selbst den Ausweis zeigen
wahrscheinlich.
Entwurf müssen Daten gespeichert, aber keine zusätzlichen Daten erhoben werden, habe ich
schon nicht verstanden, denn eigentlich klar, muss ich ja bislang keine weiteren Daten angeben,
wenn ich eine E-Mail-Account mir dazu lege, es gibt aber noch einen anderen Passus, da
geht es darum, dass man verpflichtet wird, gewisse Identifizierungsmerkmale zu erheben,
zu verifizieren und im Einzelfall Sicherheitsbehörden zur Verfügung zu stellen, somit kann zur
Aufklärung von Straftaten im Einzelfall die Anonymität aufgehoben werden.
Also, das ist natürlich grundsätzlich gegen diese, das ist ja auch ein Argument, was
immer kommt, so nach dem Motto, wir brauchen das, damit wir Straftaten besser verfolgen
können.
Das verstehe ich sogar bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, das Problem ist, dass man sich die
letzten Jahre über, und man hat es jetzt auch bei Corona wieder gesehen, das Vertrauen
in die Glaubwürdigkeit der Aussagen komplett verspielt hat, also sprich, heute wird gesagt,
hey, wir erheben das nur für Mord, Totschlag, Kindesmissbrauch und sonst was.
Da wird keiner was dagegen sagen, da wird alle sagen, ok, leuchtet ein, wobei man auch
schon da, wenn man die, wenn man in der Vergangenheit das verfolgt hat, auch schon da misstrauisch
werden sollte.
So, das wird immer angeführt, weil das ist was, da kann keiner was dagegen sagen.
So, als nächstes kommt dann, ah, wir könnten das vielleicht auch für Steuerhinterziehung
verwenden, ah, vielleicht verwenden wir es auch bei nicht ganz so schweren Dingern, ah,
vielleicht sollte man da vielleicht einem Abmahnanwalt auch Zugriff drauf geben und
sowas.
Und das wird immer weiter aufgeweicht, bis dann am Endeffekt der Scheiß für jeden Furz
verwendet wird.
Und das hast du jetzt auch in der letzten Zeit wieder deutlich gesehen, als einfach Aussagen
gemacht werden, also von der Regierung, die schon ein paar Wochen später komplett selbst
dagegen verstoßen wird.
Zum Beispiel hieß es, die Corona-Daten für, wo man sich aufhält, wo man einträgt, wo
man gewesen ist zum Essen, ihr könnt euch ja dran erinnern, wo man das eintragen muss,
sind ganz streng zweckgebunden zum Nachverfolgen von der Infektion.
Hat jedem eingeläuft, hat jeder mitgemacht, zumindest die meisten, alles gut, und da kam
die bayerische Polizei und hat gemacht, ah, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, wir brauchen das
für die Strafe, nee, da haben wir auch Zugriff drauf.
Das ist das Problem, du kannst den Aussagen nicht trauen.
Natürlich sagt keiner was dagegen, dass man was gegen Mord, Totschlag und Kindesmissbrauch
machen muss, selbstverständlich nicht, aber man hat aus der Vergangenheit ja gelernt,
dass solche Aussagen oftmals nicht sonderlich lange Bestand haben.
Das ist halt das Problem, und nachdem man sich dieses Vertrauen komplett verspielt hat,
muss man sich nicht wundern, dass so viele Leute einfach aus Prinzip gar nichts mehr
glauben, was gesagt wird in der Richtung, selbst schuld.
Sind sehr, also ehrlicherweise die Straftäter, die holen sich da jetzt nicht mit dem Ausweis
und Whatsapp.
Genau, und dazu kommt jemand, der wirklich so diese schwerwiegenden Straftaten begehen
will oder einen Auftragsmord vergibt oder so, der macht das ja nicht, ich will nicht ausschließen,
dass es den einen oder anderen doofen gibt, der das macht, aber die Auftragskiller werden
wahrscheinlich ihre Aufträge auch nicht per Whatsapp mit einem kontrollierten Handy und
registriertem Account entgegennehmen.
Man kriegt ja völlig die falschen, das ist wieder eine Datensammelwut, da kriege ich
ehrlicherweise schon wieder ein bisschen zu viel.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Es geht darum, dass die Anbieter verpflichtet werden sollen, eben die Identifizierungsmerkmal
aufzunehmen und das ist jetzt noch einen Tacken weiter eigentlich als bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
da ging es ja schon um die IP-Adressen, da wurde ja schon sehr lange darüber gestritten,
hat Oktober 2020 glaube ich der Europäische Gerichtshof gesagt, dass in gewissem Rahmen
eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung leid zumindest möglich sein soll, okay, aber das geht jetzt
echt deutlich darüber hinaus.
Bislang in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das war ja eh immer sehr, sehr brisant, das wird
schon seit 2007 ehrlicherweise versucht, da uns eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung reinzudrücken,
dann gab es 2017 wieder was Neues, es ist eine typische Salamitaktik wieder.
Kategorien von Daten, die im Rahmen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gespeichert werden sollten, Standortdaten
bei Aufnahme eines Telefonats über das Mobiltelefon, sowohl für den der Anruf als auch der angerufene
Standortdaten zu Beginn der mobilen Internetnutzung, inklusive WhatsApp-Nutzung, Telefonaten,
SMS, IP-Adressen, ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr, habe ich hier schon häufiger was
zu gemacht.
EuGH hat gesagt, ja in gewissem Rahmen zu ganz schweren Straftaten kann das alles möglich
sein, jetzt muss da wieder was kommen, es hat ja Oktober 2020 gesagt, ich glaube wir
haben da jetzt noch kein neues Gesetz, aber es ging immer hin und her, habe ich hier schon
häufig darüber berichtet.
Spannender allerdings, was jetzt sonst noch im Gesetz im Papier des Bundesinnenministeriums
steht, der Entwurf zum Telekommunikationsgesetz, noch ist nichts verabschiedet, aber das ist
der Plan des Innenministeriums.
14 weitere strittige Punkte, die haben es in sich, so z.B. sollen Internetcafés, Krankenhäuser,
Hotels verpflichtet werden, Daten für die Sicherheitsbehörden zu erheben, also geht
ihr künftig in den Internetcafé, müsst da auch erstmal ein Perso auf den Tisch legen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da noch zu sagen soll.
Also ihr solltet an keinem Point mehr ins Internet kommen, ohne euch vorher zu identifizieren.
Das ist doch irre, oder der Kreis derer, die Daten für eine spätere mögliche Auskunft
an den Staatsspeicher müssen, wird in großem Stil einfach ausgebaut.
Außerdem will das Innenministerium Unternehmen, die den Internetzugang anbieten, verpflichten
im Rahmen der Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung sozusagen Onlinedurchsuchungen Hilfestellungen
zu gewähren.
Das heißt, man soll in dem Moment, wo jemand online ist, denen noch mehr helfen, dass sie
jemanden erwischen können.
Also sprich, sie wollen jetzt die Provider dazu verpflichten, dass die ihnen helfen,
ihre eigenen Kunden zu durchsuchen.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum sich manche Leute vielleicht hinter
das Unity Media Modem oder hinter das Vodafone Modem nochmal was eigenes stellen, weil ansonsten
sind ja direkt an euren Desktop-PCs dran.
Bis jetzt natürlich noch reine Fiktion, aber, oder was heißt, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das
noch reine Fiktion ist, dann, vielleicht habt ihr ja den falschen Text auf eine Überweisung
geschrieben und man denkt jetzt ihr seid Terrorist oder so.
Anbieten verpflichten im Rahmen der Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung sozusagen Onlinedurchsuchungen Hilfestellungen
zu gewähren.
Das heißt, man soll in dem Moment, wo jemand online ist, denen noch mehr helfen, dass sie
jemanden erwischen können.
Das vollständige Papier seht ihr bei Netzpolitik.org, die haben das komplett veröffentlicht, wer
das nachlesen will.
Es ist wieder so eine Schnapsidee, meines Erachtens wird das so in der Form so groß
nicht durchgehen, denn die Wirkungen sind in meinen Augen noch viel größer als bei
der Vorratsdatenspreisung.
Ja.
Also klar kann man auch anders argumentieren, Vorratsdatenspreisung geht es um die ständige
Kommunikation, aber hier ist ja nun wirklich so, vielleicht muss man es auch so in Kombination
mit der Vorratsdatenspreisung.
Die IP-Adresse wird geknüpft meinetwegen an irgendeinen WhatsApp-Account, ja, bislang
konnten die das nicht nachvollziehen, von wem das alles kam, jetzt gibt man Adresse
von dem, dessen WhatsApp-Account das ist.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen, es wird doch dazu führen, dass die Leute dann
einfach in den USA ihren E-Mail-Account anlegen, da muss man es nicht registrieren, das klappt
doch wieder nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich halte davon im Moment, das merkt ihr gerade, so können wir es mal
gar nichts.
In der Theorie ist Facebook dran, Facebook-Messenger, Instagram-Messenger sind alles alles Messenger-Dienste,
könnte man alle genauso mit reinziehen.
Ich tippe nur, dass dann das eine oder andere Unternehmen, was so E-Mail-Dienste anbietet,
sich denkt, ja, das machen wir doch dann lieber mal so, dass wir im, ins Ausland das Ganze
verlegen.
Dummerweise ist es dann doch wieder relativ weit fortgeschritten, am 25.
Juni soll das Ganze zum letzten Mal im Bundestag gelesen werden, oder beziehungsweise Tag dort
zum letzten Mal.
Das heißt, das schreitet jetzt in diesem Jahre schon wieder sehr voran.
Praktisch, weil Demos können wir jetzt auch nicht organisieren, es ist ja gerade Corona.
Also ich bin da ein bisschen, denkst so, boah, meine Güte, ja, aber mein Gott, ja, das
ist die Mehrheit, die Volk wählt da, die Jungs, die hier so Hardliner sind, ich würde das
jetzt nicht beim nächsten Wahlen, die ja auch bald schon wieder sind, noch mal wählen,
ja, also ohne Scheiß, ja, wer…
Normalerweise, normalerweise ist aber sowas ja nicht so direkt, ja.
Sowas hier reindrücken will und sagt, wir müssen noch mehr überwachen, ich glaube,
dass wir schon ganz handlungsfähig sind als Staat und nicht noch mehr unsere Bürger überwachen
müssen, da bin ich ehrlicherweise, und das sage ich ja auch ganz offen, relativ zurückhaltend.
Wo ich nicht zurückhaltend bin, ist in der Beobachtung dieses Themas, das werdet ihr
wissen und deswegen lasst gerne ein Abo da, dann seid ihr immer up to date.
Wie sind denn eigentlich so die aktuellen Umfragewerte?
Umfrage, Bundestagswahl 21.
Wo gibt es denn da was Aktuelles?
Ok, Spiegelumfrage ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Wow!
Ok.
Wo gibt es denn da was Aussagekräftiges?
Umfragen und Prognosen.
Aktuelle Umfragen, der letzten zwei Wochen.
Moment, was zum…
Ok, ich wollte gerade sagen, die SPD kriegt doch im Leben kein 20%.
Dass die SPD überhaupt 10% kriegt, ähm, wo sind wir denn hier?
Boah, krass, schau mal, wir sind mal hier, 26 und, also die träumen ja gefühlt eh schon
davon, dass sie hier koalieren können zur nächsten Bundestagswahl, das wird ja wahrscheinlich
dann auch funktionieren, so halbwegs, irgendwie, schwierig, äh, tja, interessant.
Naja, das Problem was ich gerade vor allem bei den Grünen sehe ist, ich finde die erzählen
durchaus einiges sinnvolles Zeug, ich habe so den Eindruck, die Grünen erzählen einfach
alles was Punkte bringt, so nach dem Motto, kostenlosen Nahverkehr, machen wir super Wirtschaft,
machen wir super Umweltschutz, machen wir, äh, das, Infrastruktur machen wir, mehr Bildung
machen wir, ähm, bessere Ausung machen wir auch und, du kannst ja schlecht, also ich meine,
du kannst das schon sagen, aber so ohne, es gibt halt Sachen, die passen echt schlecht
zusammen, ja, also super Umweltschutz und Wirtschaft eins zu eins, so wie es jetzt ist,
weiter, das funktioniert halt nicht und ich bin da mal gespannt, ja, ähm, ich bin übrigens
der Meinung, und nicht weil ich großartiger Fan der AfD bin, ich bin der Meinung, die
AfD sollte mal wirklich, sei es auch nur auf Länderebene, mal in die Regierung kommen,
also, dann sieht man nämlich, dass da auch nur viel geschwätzt wird und wenn man mal
was zu sagen hat, nicht viel passiert, das hat man nämlich zum Beispiel gesehen, bei
den Grünen in Hessen, wir haben einen grünen Umweltminister und mit was die angetreten
sind, äh, es wird am Frankfurter Flughafen nicht ausgebaut, ähm, Nachtflugverbot, bla
bla bla und, ähm, alles das, was sie gesagt haben vor der Wahl, mit uns wird es das definitiv
nicht geben, alles das ist gekommen, in Hessen zumindest, ja, ähm, deswegen bin ich mir
relativ sicher, wenn einer von der AfD, oder wenn die AfD mit in der Regierung wäre, in
manchen Ländern, da würde man sehen, dass da auch von dem was erzählt wird, nicht viel
passiert, also sprich, dass sie das auch nicht besser können, ähm, deswegen bin ich der
Meinung, es wäre gar nicht mal so schlecht, wenn die in ein paar Regierungen landen, aber
hey, wenn die das weiterhin so verkacken, dann wird das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal
lange dauern.
Ja, aber es ist echt, es ist echt der Wahnsinn, also, wenn die so weitermachen mit der aktuellen
Politik und Corona, da sind ja die Grünen irgendwann, dann haben wir ja die Grünen
am Start als, als stärkste Partei in der Bundestagswahl, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, da bin ich ja
mal gespannt, dann können sie sich nicht mehr rausreden, so nach dem Motto, hey, wir können
jetzt ja nichts machen, weil wir sind ja nur klein und nur mit dabei, also nicht so wie
in Hessen, sondern, dann müssten sie auch mal zeigen, dass es klappt, was sie so vorschlagen.
Äh, der Defender ist ziemlich gut mittlerweile, ja, was sich in dem China-Leser-Ordner befindet,
China-Zeug, tatsächlich China-Zeug, ähm, genau, also wie gesagt, ich würde den Windows
da nehmen und sonst einfach nix Gutes.
Äh, wie heißt das, was du mit CloudFern an einem DNS-Hausnamen gemacht hast, möchte
danach googeln.
Äh, ein DNS-Eintrag für meinen Hausnamen, also A-Rekord, ganz normalen DNS-Eintrag.
Soll den Impfpass nicht ALBM machen, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich weiß nur, dass an der Corona-App
waren ja ganz viele super highly paid Consultants am Start von SAP und der Telekom und es hat
ja immerhin halbwegs hingehauen, hingehauen muss man sagen.
So, was stehen geblieben hier?
Was ist Bria, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was ist Echo-Chat, das hört sich an wie irgendwie, irgendwas, wo Camgirls benutzen oder so.
Das geheime Tagebuch der Gangster, oh der Titel schon, ich lese den Chat so schnell,
ja kein Problem, ich benutze Kura, durch scrollen so an, KennymanGear, Dankeschön für den
Sub und King Graham auch am Start, nice, IQ++, wer will Kinder ehen, wer will ernsthaft
Kinder ehen von denen, hä, du meinst die Grünen, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
wobei die haben schon ein paar Verrückte dabei, die haben auch letztens erzählt, die
haben auch letztens erzählt, dass wenn ein Arzt persönliche Probleme damit hat Abtreibungen
durchzuführen, dann dürfte er in keinem Krankenhaus mehr arbeiten, also die haben manchmal
schon echt äußerst fragwürdige Dinge, was die erzählen, aber letztendlich, du kannst
eigentlich keine Partei ausnehmen, wo du nicht Leute hast, auch teilweise zum Großteil die
strumpfsinn erzählen, ja, du musst im Prinzip immer gucken, was ist das, die noch am meisten,
am öftesten das erzählen, was mir wichtig ist, so Sachen, die, die gar keinen Mist
erzählen, findest du ja gar nicht, vier Jahre Stillstunde, ja, das hast du jetzt auch schon,
ich fände es nur mal interessant, ich sag ja gar nicht in der Bundesregierung, ich fände
es nur mal interessant, sie sind ja aktuell richtig krass dabei, über alles zu meckern,
das schlecht ist, man muss fair und das halber sagen, sogar bei einigen Sachen echt zurecht,
ja, aber ich stell mir das genauso vor, wie es beispielsweise mit den Grünen in Hessen
ist, wenn die am Start sind und mal zeigen müssen, mal was machen müssen, dass das auch
nicht funktioniert, und vielleicht sehen ein paar Leute mal, dass das auch schwachsinnig
ist, oder aber, es passiert das, was keiner erwartet, sie machen was Gescheites, wir wollen
es ja nicht ausschließen, ja, aber da hab ich meinen Zweifel, dass da irgendjemand
was Gescheites macht, Charcoal 22, danke schön für den Sub, äh, nee, ich mach eigentlich
nur die Domains und ich hab den Preis-Champ hinter Cloudflare als Proxy, es gibt ja auch
noch nichts, mit dem man verschlüsselt kommunizieren kann, ne, man muss da natürlich was eigenes
bauen, weil es gibt ja noch keine Möglichkeit verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren, Zeit koste
da eigentlich schon für den Sub, ja, das müsst ihr halt mal zeigen, deswegen, ich
finde, ich finde das eigentlich vom Ansatz her gar nicht so verkehrt, es muss ja nicht
gleich in der Bundesregierung sein, ich gehe nämlich stark davon aus, es wird einfach
gar nichts passieren, also sprich, im Prinzip läuft es genauso weiter wie vorher, mit oder
ohne Beteiligung und alles das, was im Vorfeld erzählt wurde, wird nicht gemacht, so wie
im Prinzip bei den meisten anderen auch, aber dann haben sie noch mehr, ja, vielleicht ist
ja das, was die Leute wollen, das wollen viele, ja, was meint ihr, warum da CDU oder CSU und
CSU auch so viele Leute wegrennen, das ist den nicht, äh, das ist ja nicht mal oldschool
genug, aber ich kann es auch insofern verstehen, also ich weiß auch nicht, was ich wählen
soll, ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich bin echt total unentschlossen, am liebsten würde
ich ja eigentlich gar nicht wählen, aber das auch ungültig wählen ist auch bescheuern,
die Grünen erzählen auch so viel Zeug, wenn der Tag lang ist, wo ich mich immer frage,
wie soll man das alles unter einen Hut kriegen, zweifelsweise wähle ich einfach die Tierschutzpartei
oder irgendein Schwachsinn, womit zumindest ein Anliegen wichtig ist, ja, ja, die Piraten,
die Piraten, die haben sich ja irgendwie selbst piratet, die gibt es dann immer, so wirklich,
also die, die waren vor ein paar Jahren mal ganz, ganz gut aufstrebend, aber jetzt ist
es vorbei, auspirateriert, was, diese ganzen random Parteien, die kriegen im Leben nicht
die 5%, die sind schon etwas größer, ich habe von denen mal irgendwann mal kurz was
gehört, aber das war's, ja, mache ich schon immer, so, genug wichtige Themen erörtert,
wir haben noch 10 Minuten Zeit oder so, was machen wir jetzt noch, ich habe mir doch irgendwas
aufgeschrieben, was ich euch noch sagen wollte, wartet mal, was haben wir denn hier, achso,
ich muss, äh, übrigens, Hetzner hatte mich ja angeschrieben, ob wir nicht ein bisschen
sponsoring Geschichten machen wollen und ich habe geantwortet und jetzt hat Hetzner auch
wieder geantwortet, ob wir uns nicht mal zusammensetzen wollen, ich glaube, da könnte sich demnächst
was ergeben, die Champ-Partei, die agile Champ-Partei, AGACP, agile Champ-Partei, du hast mal geantwortet,
ja, ich habe geantwortet, die Scrum-Partei, das wäre doch mal was, jeden Tag, jeden Tag
Daily Stand-Up Scrum, das ist, für die Scrum-Partei bin ich dabei, die Scrum-Partei, das ist
die beste Idee, was man machen könnte, Partei-Champ, äh, genau, also, warte mal, es gab doch noch
irgendwas, was ich euch erzählen wollte, ich finde es nicht, übrigens, Leute, ich habe mir zum ersten
Mal in meinem Leben bei Amazon Feuerzeuge bestellt, so ein ganz billiges, ganz, nein, ich rauche nicht,
so ein ganz billiges Set, weil ich festgestellt habe, dass irgendwie sowas hier, so kleine,
zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, dass ich mir Feuerzeuge bestellt habe, damit ich Schrumpf-Schläuche
und so ordentlich Schrumpf-Champen kann, weil bisher mache ich das immer mit meiner Heißluft-Pistole
und das ist halt immer nervig, die aus dem Schrank zu holen für einen Schrumpf-Schläuch und außerdem
ist die auch viel zu fett für so einen kleinen Schrumpf-Schläuch. Gesetzesentwürfe als User-Stories,
hey, weißt du was, die Idee finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, dann wäre das mal wenigstens
ein bisschen aus Sicht der Leute, die das dann ausbaden müssen. Jeder Prepper fängt mit
Feuerzeugen an, ja, kann schon sein, aber ich habe doch eh gepreppt mit meinem, mit meinem Speer im,
mit meinem Speer im Flur. Okay, die Leute, die nicht dabei waren, die nicht dabei waren, als ich das
erzählt habe, die fragen sich jetzt, was habe ich für einen Speer im Flur? Nein, ich habe nicht
wirklich einen Speer im Flur, ich habe von, ich habe von einem Zaun, ach so, ja, ein Nachsichtgerät,
klar, braucht man, braucht man. Ich habe von einem Zaun so ein zwei Meter langes, oder das ist
ungefähr ein zwei Meter langes, wie nennt man das, Stab aufgehoben, wie nennt man das, Rippe,
keine Ahnung, so ein Zaun, so ein Zaunteil, so ein grünes, grünes Zaunteil aufgehoben, so ein
ungefähr zwei Meter langer Stab mit Spitze, Fahl, Holz, nein, nein, das ist schon aus Metall,
aber es ist Hol innen drin, das kann man, kann man nehmen, ist jetzt nicht super schwer und das
habe ich hier oben im Flur liegen, an der Wand, ohne Mist, ich habe mir gedacht, hey, eines hebe
ich mir auf, eins hebe ich mir auf davon, so eine Art Rohr, viereckiges Rohr, also das ist das
viereckige, der Zaun und ich habe mir gedacht, eins hebe ich mir auf, der restliche Zaun ist Ripp,
da ist jetzt neuer, größerer, so mit, dass die Katze nicht durchkommt, aber von dem alten habe
ich mir das aufgehoben und zwar, ich dachte mir so, um einen Speer genau, und ich dachte mir so, hey,
das ist eigentlich ne super Sache, den legst du dir oben im Flur, sollte wirklich mal der Fall sein,
dass irgendjemand einbricht oder, dass du das Fenster auf hast und es springt jemand rein oder
so und du musst Leute aus deiner, aus deiner Wohnung, aus meinem Haus vertreiben, dann nehme
ich meinen Speer und wenn die die Treppe hoch wollen, werden sie gesteppt, beste Idee, ich
weiß, ich dachte mir, es ist nicht verkehrt, wenn man irgendwas liegen hat, was willst du machen,
ein Doppelstabmattenzaun Verbindungselement, Moment, Doppelstab, nee, nein, nein, nein,
nicht sowas, das war noch, das ist ein richtiger Oldschoolzaun gewesen, mit eher sowas, nee,
Schwachsinn, Zaun, eher sowas hier, nur länger und spitzer, das habe ich im Flur und wenn
einer einbricht, bin ich gesteppt, irgendwas musst du machen, du kannst ja schlecht zum
Einbrecher sagen, lass uns erstmal Stand-up-Meeting machen, wo du am besten Sachen findest, ein bisschen
was liegen haben ist ja nicht verkehrt, einfach mitsuchen, der Einbrecher wird vom geflashten
Staubsauer gebashed, ich finde Gedanken sollte sich jeder darum machen, was passiert, wenn
mal einer bei ihm im Haus ist, der nicht soll, also ich meine mal Gedanken drüber machen
schadet ja nichts, es ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich, dass was ist, und ich glaube nicht, dass in
nächster Zeit was passiert, aber sich mal da Gedanken drüber zu machen schadet nicht,
und man muss sagen, so unwahrscheinlich ist das jetzt auch nicht, also ich weiß das bei
uns, also nicht direkt bei uns in der Straße, aber um die Ecke in der Straße, das hat, was
war das vor einem Monat oder so, war Polizei und alles am Start, also das ist nicht so
weit hergeholt ja, Teilen und Bohrungen, ey ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen auf YouTube,
da haben sie eine Schnellschuss-Armbrust, nein ich meine nicht den Slingshot-Channel,
der ist cool, den meine ich nicht, den kenne ich auch, den kenne ich wahrscheinlich auch,
der hat einer eine Armbrust vorgestellt zum Verteidigen von seinem Grundstück mit Schnellladefunktion,
also sowas wie auch, wie er auch auf dem Slingshot-Channel gezeigt hat, so eine Armbrust, jetzt muss
ich euch mal zeigen, Instant, genau, das Ding ist mega geil, ich muss einfach zeigen, ja,
das Ding ist brutal und das kannst du mega schnell nachladen, guckt euch das mal an,
pass mal auf, cool, easy, rapid fire Leute, rapid fire, ich finde schon cool das Teil,
ne, aber das habe ich letztens auf dem Channel gesehen, das hat einer wirklich vorgestellt
zum Haus, zum Grundstück verteidigen, ey, damit verteidigst du es sicherlich gut, muss
halt treffen, ja ok, aber, also wenn du so ein Ding abkriegst, dann machst du wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr viel, außer versuchen abzuhauen, falls du noch kannst, also das hat schon, wo
bist du, was die Dinger sind nicht mehr erlaubt, oh, FitzBatman, ne, da hat er ja nicht so
Unrecht, die Idee ist ja nicht verkehrt, aber da wirst du halt nicht durchsetzen können,
der ist aus, der kommt doch aus Deutschland, der Typ, der lebt doch hier, das Linkshot Channel,
man, also, der wird schon gucken, dass das legal ist, ja leider, leider, so ein Granatenwerfer
wäre schon geil zum Haus verteidigen, allerdings muss ich sagen, du machst ja das Haus damit
auch teilweise kaputt, das ist dann auch nicht so geil, erstmal Noobtube daheim rausholen,
ja, Leute, ich muss ins Bett, wir sehen uns, was ist das, diese Alarmallage, das kenne
ich, ja, das ist Fail, genauso, die beste, die, die, die, Leute, Leute, die beste Selbstverteidigungsanleitung
ist immer noch der Typ hier, bitte helfen sie mir, der Typ, das, das ist, das ist der
beste, Alter, was ist das für eine fucking Qualität, gibt es das nicht in guter Auflösung,
aber das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das ist der beste, der Typ, pass mal auf, das
ist so krass, halt, bitte helfen sie mir, ja, das schreckt, dass ich überlege mir gerade,
irgend so ein völlig verrückter drogenabhängiger Typ kommt mir in Frankfurt entgegen, ja, und
ich sage erstmal halt, und sag dann zu meinem Nehmer, bitte helfen sie mir, das schreckt
ihn bestimmt wahnsinnig ab, ja, bitte Sempervideos reden, kann man machen, so geil, oder, ok,
Sempervideos twitched, ist er am Start, oh, was ist das, ok, ich mach den Rage schon mal
rein, ja, der Nissan Leaf ist ja gut, ist das jetzt live, oder ist das ein aufgenommenes
Video, jetzt ist ja mal gut, Nissan Drive, Nissan Drive, jetzt komm, ok Leute, alles
klar, dann hause ich ihn jetzt mal, wir sehen uns, machts gut, bis dann, see you.